ah pour ça on vise de de d'être présent
à la prochaine COP à Glasgow en espérant
qu'elle aura lieu correctement un qui
aura lieu en présentiel et le but sur
place c'est de faire un lobbying pour
continuer de pousser nos sujets qui sont
la sensibilisation aux enjeux
climatiques à Glasgow il y aura des
négociations sur le climat il y a une
des thématiques de ces négociations qui
s'appelle action for climot emperment et
qui porte sur notre sujet qui est la
formation et la sensibilisation aux
enjeux climatiques quand on évoque ce
sujet aujourd'hui dans les négo climats
on a des gens qui viennent nous dire oui
on fait des choses on explique
l'environnement aux enfants dans les
écoles voilà et nous on y va on va aller
à Glasgow pour dire non non c'est pas ça
qu'il faut faire il faut expliquer le
climat au décideurs politiques et
économique c'est pas juste une histoire
de d'apprendre à trier ses déchets dans
les enfants dans les dans les écoles
avec les enfants c'est surtout une
histoire de mettre le au bon niveau chez
les décideurs
on a fait les fresques avec des députés
avec des hommes politiques et des femmes
politiques on sait que leur niveau de
connaissances sur le sujet n'est pas
encore suffisant pour pouvoir prendre
des décisions correctement et notre
combat il est là il est d'amener cette
connaissance partout donc je pense que
vous avez tous ceux qui sont là ont déjà
joué ou animé des fresques ça marche
avec tous les publics et c'est pour ça
que c'est important de pouvoir utiliser
cet outil à la fois dans les écoles
primaires et également avec des membres
de Comex de grandes entreprises avec des
députés avec des hommes et des femmes
politiques et c'est ça que l'on vise une
filet
le sujet de la table ronde qui vient ça
va justement être de discuté du rôle que
que peut avoir une association comme la
nôtre enfin du rôle que représente la
que porte la sensibilisation dans le
débat politique on va recevoir Etienne
Klein et Jean-Marc Jancovici
qui sont qui sont tous les deux
travaillent tous les deux sur ce sujet
de la sensibilisation donc j'encovici
pour parce que il a depuis très
longtemps fait de la vulgarisation et je
pense que la plupart d'entre nous ici on
est venu sur ce sujet grâce à lui moi y
compris Étienne Klein et travaille il
est philosophe des sciences il travaille
sur le la relation entre la science et
la société et c'est pile poil dans notre
dans notre sujet et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a on a voulu leur demander
d'intervenir ce matin voilà je vais
maintenant laisser la parole à Juliette
que vous connaissez certainement tous
qui va animer ce premier débat Juliette
c'est à toi merci à vous
merci alors bonjour à toutes et à tous
je vais accueillir Etienne Klein je
voudrais dire que nous sommes super
contents à l'association de pouvoir
inaugurer
ces trois jours avec Étienne Klein et
j'espère Jean-Marc jorgovici qui donne
ne devrait pas tarder donc merci d'être
là en fait moi je vais me mettre là mais
mettez-vous là en attendant que
Jean-Marc arrive
donc on avait prévu
que Étienne présente Jean-Marc et que
Jean-Marc présentait tienne mais ce
n'est pas possible
alors Étienne m'a présenté présenter
Jean-Marc
bonjour à toutes et à tous d'abord merci
pour l'invitation qui meurt et qui me
qui me réjouit je connais vos activités
qui m'impressionnent je suis pas
climatologue je dis à le dire tout de
suite alors présenter Jean-Marc
d'abord que Jean-Marc c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est jamais en retard en fait il
installe un suspense ce qui est tout à
fait différent
et sinon il est il est polytechnicien
donc respect il a fondé carbone 4 je
crois avec
un
2004 je crois c'est quelqu'un qui est
très engagé sur les questions qui vous
intéressent évidemment qui est un grand
pédagogue passionné et c'est quelqu'un
qui prend très très au sérieux
l'anagramme du mot climato-sceptique
l'anagramme de climato-sceptique c'est
complice statique voilà et je trouve que
ça
bravo c'est vous qui l'avez trouvé
non c'est alors je sais plus qu'il a
trouvé celle-là je crois que c'est
Olivier Garcia d'accord
mais elle mérite d'être publié je crois
tout à fait et pour compléter la
présente la présentation de Jean-Marc
qui n'est toujours pas là il est
également président de l'association the
shift project voilà
alors moi je vais vous présenter à la
place de Jean-Marc alors certainement
pas avec ces mots mais Étienne Klein
donc vous dirigez le laboratoires du CEA
dans lequel on effectue des recherches
dans le domaine de la philosophie de la
physique et de l'éthique appliquée et
vous êtes également enseignant de
philosophie des sciences à
centralesupélec et membre de l'Académie
des technologies
tout y est et j'ajoute que vous êtes
également auteur de très nombreux essais
de vulgarisation et même si ce n'est pas
vous qui l'avez créé il y a un site
internet en votre nom voilà qui qui a
été créé par des étudiants
certains de mes étudiants qui dans leur
cadre de projet de fin d'études ont
réalisé sans m'en parler
un site qui porte mon nom dans lequel il
y a des extraits de livres des
commentaires des articles de
vulgarisation sur des questions de
physique
donc nous allons commencer par la
première séquence
et j'avais envie moi de de m'attarder
deux minutes sur les difficultés propres
aux messages puisque la fresque du
climat son but est de faire comprendre
les causes et les conséquences du
changement climatique et il y a vraiment
des difficultés propres à ce message
puisque sensibiliser sur le changement
climatique c'est s'adresser à la fois à
notre tête pour comprendre les
mécanismes à notre cœur or ça déclenche
des émotions et souvent du déni voire de
l'évitement et au final à nos jambes
puisque passer à l'action c'est quand
même le but final ma question c'est en
fait comment s'y prendre pour que tout
s'enchaîne et que on ne reste pas bloqué
à l'étape 1 et 2 c'est une très bonne
question que je me pose ce qui veut dire
que j'ai pas la réponse mais il se
trouve que moi j'ai presque toujours
travaillé au CEA
et jamais en climatologie mais alors que
j'ai changé plusieurs fois de
laboratoire il se trouve que le
laboratoire dans lequel je travaillais a
toujours été à côté du laboratoire de
climatologie c'est ainsi que j'ai fait
la connaissance de Jean jauzel dans les
années 1980 et il m'a parlé des sujets
qui vous occupent et le message qu'il
tenait à l'époque qui était le même que
celui que tenait d'autres climatologue
comme Jacques Duplessis par exemple
est exactement le même qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que ce sont des gens qui
disent à peu près la même chose depuis
40 ans on les écoute plus aujourd'hui
que cette époque là mais c'est le même
message et Jean jauzet et ses collègues
à la machine à café nous parlait de ces
sujets et donc
par contagion en quelque sorte on a
acquis une certaine conscience de ces
problèmes qui s'est évidemment renforcé
à la lecture des rapports successifs du
GIEC etc mais en effet c'est assez
théorique et ça correspond à des
phénomènes qu'on ne voit pas directement
même si et c'est là que l'émotion
intervient moi j'ai découvert la haute
montagne en
1978 et donc j'ai vu pour la première
fois de ma vie la mère de glace à
Chamonix et les glaciers déposons en
1978 depuis j'y retourne chaque année
et je sais exactement où est l'endroit
où j'ai appris à chausser des crampons
au pied du glacier du Bosson qui à
l'époque l'échelle la route aujourd'hui
il est 400 mètres plus haut la mer de
glace elle est plus bas
elle s'est en quelque sorte effondrée
dans la dans la partie basse et ça
provoque une émotion qui est une sorte
de traumette c'est une sorte de syndrome
pré-tromatique c'est on la regarde en
voyant ce qu'elle va devenir
ce qu'on appelle la solastalgie
sur de souffrance a priori qui vient qui
vient du fait que nous savons c'est nous
savons que nos enfants ne verront pas le
même paysage que nous et je pense que
toute la difficulté que vous soulevez
c'est bien du fait que il faut prendre
conscience d'un problème qui n'a pas
encore montré tous ces effets et c'est
là que on peut établir une connexion
avec la pandémie par exemple à un moment
il faut décider de confiner les gens
et le moment où on les confiné
est un moment où il y a pas tant de cas
que ça
mais on sait que la loi de
l'exponentielle est en scalaire ce
nombre de câbles augmenté et donc il
faut prendre une décision
qui correspond à ce que nous savons qui
va se passer si on prend pas la décision
et il faut l'imposer à un moment où les
phénomènes sur lesquels on lutte n'ont
pas encore l'importance qui vont avoir
et ça je pense que c'est c'est très
difficile ça demande une forme de
courage quand même ça demande aussi une
certaine confiance dans ce que disent
les scientifiques et on peut établir
comme ça des similitudes et s'agissant
du du climat je pense qu'on a tendance
aussi à développer ce que Hegel appelait
une conscience malheureuse conscience
malheureuse c'est quoi c'est dit-il
lorsque vous avez conscience d'un
problème
vous connaissez la solution de ce
mais elle est tellement radicale et
tellement difficile à imposer que vous
la considérez comme impossible donc vous
connaissez la solution mais elle est
impossible donc ça vous met dans une
conscience malheureuse qui vient du fait
que vous vous sentez impuissant et vous
êtes condamné en fait non pas
à résoudre le problème mais à vous
adapter
à ce qui va être et je pense que ça pour
nous pour vous surtout c'est extrêmement
difficile puisque comme vous le savez
comme le disent d'ailleurs les rapports
du GIEC pour les quelques décennies qui
viennent on est dans un régime
balistique c'est à dire que quoi que
nous allons faire quoi que nous fassions
dans les années qui viennent ça ne
changera pas l'évolution du climat dans
les années qui viennent et donc prendre
des mesures radicales sans qu'on puisse
dire qu'elles ont un effet visible
ça demande un une pédagogie d'abord mais
aussi un courage incroyable
qui sont nécessaires pour dépasser à la
fois l'optimisme et le pessimisme qui
sont deux attitudes opposées qui
conduisent finalement à la même attitude
quand vous adapté optimiste vous dites
ça va s'arranger les technologues vont
nous sortir d'affaires les scientifiques
vont trouver une nouvelle force
fondamentale on fera de l'énergie
autrement ça c'est l'optimisme qui
consiste à attendre que ça s'arrange
et puis pessimisme c'est foutu
tant qu'il y a rien à faire et vous
voyez comment à quelle vitesse on a
remplacer
l'expression lutte contre le changement
climatique
par l'expression adaptation
vous voyez c'est ça c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que mais en fait
toujours rien pour s'adapter oui mais ça
interroge la notion de risque ce qu'on
appelle un risque
ce qu'on appelle un risque il y a
plusieurs définitions mais en fait on
mesure
la réalité d'un risque
à l'aune de notre capacité à pouvoir le
réduire
autrement dit nous disons qu'un risque
est un risque si on peut imaginer des
stratagèmes qui permettent de la baisser
par exemple quand vous voyez que et là
je remonte à 1976 quand il est 16000
morts chaque année sur les routes
françaises les gens parlaient pas de
risque ils parlent pas de risque
automobile les gens disaient on veut se
déplacer librement on peut pouvoir les
vitres il y a un prix à payer très bien
puis un jour un député a dit à
l'Assemblée
bien qu'on est en train de tuer la
jeunesse de France
et c'est à ce moment là qu'une prise de
conscience a permis qu'on prenne des
mesures pour réduire ce risque
rond-point ceinture de sécurité
limitation de vitesse etc mais quand
vous n'imaginez plus de mesure capable
de réduire le risque ce risque n'est
plus un risque c'est une fatalité
et donc je pense que le défi pour vous
c'est de montrer qu'à leur même qui a
des déterminismes qui sont liés au
changement climatique les équations de
la physique sont ce qu'elles sont alors
même qu'il y a des déterminismes il y a
encore des leviers d'action
et donc c'est
une source de pédagogie extrêmement
difficile il faut alerter sur la gravité
de la situation et en même temps donner
envie d'agir mais justement vous parlez
de risque est-ce qu'il y a encore un
risque parce qu'un risque c'est un année
un aléa plus une vulnérabilité là c'est
plus tellement aléatoire le changement
climatique absolument il y a quand même
de l'incertitude qui vient du fait que
ce qui va se passer dépend partie de ce
que nous allons faire et comme nous ne
savons pas dire j'avais bien dit qu'il
était jamais en retard mais il installe
un suspense c'est pas moi c'est le RER
je peux te donner le message si tu veux
rétablissement progressivement
progressif du trafic après livraison en
retard des travaux entre Massy-Palaiseau
et les Baconnets voilà je peux te dire
qu'est-ce que je disais on parlait du
risque
oui je disais
ce qui va se passer dépend en partie de
ce que nous allons faire et comme nous
ne pouvons pas savoir ce que nous allons
faire
nous savons pas dire ce qui va se passer
avec précision et je pense que une des
grandes difficultés que vous devez
traiter surmonter en fait et là encore
je prends un exemple
venant du covid parce que
personnellement en tant que
vulgarisateur je dois dire que j'ai pris
une claque en voyant comment la science
et la recherche ont été mise en scène
pendant le covid notamment cette
confusion
qui a été presque organisée entre la
science et la recherche évidemment la
science et la recherche sont des choses
qui sont qui ne sont pas étrangères
l'une à l'autre
mais qui sont quand même différentes la
science est encore plus de connaissances
qui constitue les bonnes réponses à des
questions bien posées on parle de vérité
scientifiques pas des vérités absolues
mais quand même la terre est ronde
l'atome existe l'activité humaine a un
effet sur le climat les espèces vivantes
évoluent voilà des connaissances que
vous ne pouvez pas remettre en cause
sans avoir des arguments extrêmement
solides que peu de gens sont capables
d'imaginer
ça c'est la science qui a avoir
plutôt avec la certitude qu'avec le
doute
mais évidemment ce corpus de
connaissance il est incomplet donc il
pose des questions dont nous ne
connaissons pas les réponses et c'est
pour ça que nous faisons de la recherche
par exemple est-ce que le neutrino est
identique à son antiparticules personne
n'en sait rien les physiciens ne le
savent pas et personne d'autre que les
physiciens ne le sait
est-ce qu'il y a une vie extraterrestre
ça ne le sait
donc on fait des recherches
donc vous voyez que
le moteur de la recherche c'est le doute
et en même temps c'est son combustible
puisqu'à mesure que la recherche
progresse le doute se déplace on répond
à une question cette question pose de
nouvelles questions cette réponse pardon
pose de nouvelles questions et le tout
associé va coloniser un autre champ mais
donc vous voyez quand
le doute qui est consubstantiel à la
recherche
il y a coloniser l'idée même de sciences
et c'est ce qui se passe quand on
confond la science et la recherche alors
on en arrive à se raccourcir horrible
qui est la science c'est le doute et non
les climatologue
ne savent pas tout
pour ça qu'ils continuent à faire des
recherches
mais ils savent des choses
et la priorité c'est de tenir compte de
ce qui est sûr et aussi de savoir ce qui
n'est pas sûr
ce qui suppose que
je sais pas si vous considérez comme des
militants ou comme des pédagogues mais
je pense que les deux doivent aller
ensemble si je peux terminer avant que
je remarque parle une anecdote il y a un
peu plus de avant la pandémie vous
souvenez il y avait des grandes
manifestations auxquelles peut-être vous
participiez des jeunes pour le climat
il y a une de ces manifestations qui est
partie de Port-Royal pas loin de chez
moi et je suis allé voir les jeunes gens
qui étaient là qui se préparer
à manifester et je leur ai proposé
j'aurais demandé si c'était d'accord
pour qu'on discute ensemble avant la
mise en branle de la marche
je leur paie un café s'il accepte de
discuter avec moi il y a eu 10
volontaires
quatre élèves de terminale trois élèves
de Sciences Po et
trois élèves pour des étudiants en
première année d'université on a discuté
pendant une heure j'étais absolument
ébahi par leur maturité
intellectuelle et politique leur
conscience de la situation
de l'importance des enjeux et ils
avaient donc une conscience si vous
voulez bien supérieure à celle que
pouvait avoir les jeunes de ma
génération quand on avait leur âge
donc j'étais impressionné impressionné
mais à la fin je leur ai demandé
les amis
c'est quoi l'effet de serre
et quoi l'effet de serre c'est quoi le
mécanisme physique qu'on appelle l'effet
de serre
et aucun naturel pour nous ce qui est
pas grave du tout ils sont jeunes ils
ont la vie pour apprendre et voyez qu'il
y a un moment où la compétence
doit se corréler à la militance ou
plutôt la militance doit se corréler à
la compétence sinon sinon on peut vous
retourner comme des crêpes
et d'ailleurs moi j'avais fait semblant
de leur j'avais fait croire
j'avais rien fait croire mais je leur
avais sorti des arguments des
climato-sceptiques
et ils étaient pas capables de trouver
la parade par exemple dire messieurs 2
qu'est-ce que il y a des volcans il y a
des éruptions ça met du CO2 naturel dans
l'atmosphère en rajouter un peu
qu'est-ce que ça peut faire
et puis je leur ai dit les températures
on les mesure en degrés Celsius mais si
on les mesurant en Kelvin
passer à la fin du siècle de 15 degrés
de température moyenne à 16 degrés si on
mesure en Kelvin
c'est une variation de moins de moins
d'importance on s'en fiche
est-ce que vous aurez pu les balader
c'est ça que je veux dire
ça c'est terminé en leur conseillant de
faire une phrase du climat exactement
non mais ça dit
ça dit exactement l'importance de votre
nécessité
merci Étienne Klein Jean-Marc bonjour
Jean-Marc je vais vous reposer la
question du début que j'ai posé à
Étienne les difficultés
en retard mais j'ai rien dit les
difficultés propres messages
donc je répète très rapidement
sensibiliser sur le changement
climatique ça s'adresse à la fois à
notre tête puisqu'il faut comprendre
faire comprendre les mécanismes du
changement climatique à notre cœur et
c'est compliqué puisque ça provoque
enfin c'est assez anxiogène et donc ça
peut provoquer de l'évitement ou du déni
et enfin à nos jambes et ça c'est au
final c'est le but c'est de faire passer
les gens à l'action or on constate
souvent que on s'arrête ça bloque à la
première ou à la deuxième étape comment
faire pour parvenir à la troisième étape
qui est passé à l'action la rédemption
si j'avais la réponse serait un homme
heureux le d'abord je vais dire que je
suis très impressionné par ce qu'est
devenu la fresque du climat en quelques
années
parce que c'est né quoi il y a 4 5 4 ans
50 ans ça dépend de quoi on parle enfin
bon c'est un mouvement qui est très
jeune
et je suis
vraiment je suis très impressionné par
la vitesse à laquelle ça s'est développé
donc bravo le la réponse à ça je pense
que on a eu un petit un petit aperçu
dans le ce qui s'est passé avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
j'ai pas là j'ai pas la réponse à cette
question de façon exhaustive mais enfin
j'ai au moins quelques conditions du
succès qui me paraissent importante la
première c'est que je rejoins tout à
fait ce que vient de dire Étienne il y a
une maxime concite souvent qui est
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme alors j'ai envie de paraphraser
ce que vient de dire Étienne en disant
militantisme sans compréhension c'est la
porte ouverte à tous les dangers
et donc je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec lui moi j'ai vécu une hé je me
rappelle plus sur quoi mais j'avais vécu
une expérience similaire il y a pas très
longtemps elle discutait avec quelques
dizaines de personnes je sais plus où
lors d'une conférence et puis ils
avaient tous un avis sur un document je
leur ai demandé qui il avait lu et pas
une paire pas une mince élevée bon donc
le
je pense que effectivement il y a une
première condition du du succès qui est
de bien comprendre même si c'est un peu
désagréable mais c'est moins désagréable
quand on le fait ensemble donc il y a un
truc que il y a un truc que la
convention citoyenne a bien montré c'est
que être plusieurs avoir un collectif
quand on apprend quelque chose de
désagréable c'est ça lève une partie de
l'angoisse par rapport au fait
d'apprendre au sol donc c'est aussi je
pense un des facteurs explicatifs du
succès de la fresque c'est que c'est un
apprentissage collectif c'est à dire
qu'en fait les gens apprennent en plus
ils apprennent en cherchant et quand on
cherche c'est le jeu de piste c'est des
trucs de scout etc c'est toujours plus
c'est plus rigolo que quand on est
passif sur protège même quand on est
plusieurs dans une classe à apprendre
donc il y a un côté
j'ai envie de dire il y a des techniques
pédagogiques qui font que la
compréhension peut passer plus ou moins
facilement
et ensuite le deuxième truc que j'ai
retenu alors je vais pas là en train de
dire les 150 propositions ou les 140
j'ai plus de la convention était toute
bonne à prendre par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'à partir du moment
où les gens réfléchissent ensemble et se
mettent ensemble à se demander comment
on fait pour avancer c'est plus facile
pour eux que quand chacun réfléchit dans
son coin donc il y a un côté
collectif dans le fait de se demander ce
qu'on est capable de faire qui renforce
à mon avis la détermination parce que
une partie des propositions qui a été
faite était des propositions qui étaient
restrictives y compris pour les gens qui
ont fait des propositions et que très
probablement ils auraient jamais fait
seul dans leur coin avant cet exercice
on le constate également avec un une
espèce de jeu autour de l'empreinte
carbone que carbone 4 a lancé il y a un
an et demi qui s'appelle my cyoto et du
reste on fait souvent en tandem avec
avec la fresque on s'est rendu compte
que de faire ce genre de truc en groupe
dans des réunions Tupperware en gros ça
a changé la dynamique par rapport à le
faire de son côté tout seul dans son
points derrière un écran chez soi
puisque des calculateurs d'empreintes
carbone ça existe depuis très longtemps
et en fait quand les gens le font seul
dans leur coin
en fait je pense que si il passe à
l'action après avoir fait ce genre de
truc c'est que ils viennent juste se
conforter avec le calculateur sur le
fait que ils avaient raison de vouloir
passer à l'action je suis pas sûr que ça
marche dans l'autre sens alors que quand
ils font ce genre d'exercice de manière
collective c'est plus facile donc je
pense que l'un des déterminants du
passage à l'action et dans la forme
beaucoup plus que dans le fond c'est
dans le fait de faire des des groupes on
le voit bien aussi avec l'action locale
c'est plus facile de faire quelque chose
d'utile localement n'importe quoi
changer le régime alimentaire dans une
cantine elle est allée n'importe quoi
organiser du covoiturage c'est plus
facile de le faire quand il y a un
groupe de gens qui sont qui ont envie de
faire quelque chose ensemble plutôt que
quand on le fait seul donc le passage à
l'action il est il tient pour moi pour
partir à la forme dans laquelle on dans
laquelle on va loger loger l'action et
quelque chose qui est intermédiaire
entre tout seul où on n'a pas envie et
trop de monde où c'est trop compliqué
donc les grands plans venant du haut se
heurte à cette limite je dis pas qu'ils
sont pas nécessaires une planification
d'ensemble chez le premier à eu
souscrire mais ça peut pas être
suffisant et en particulier c'est jamais
ça qui déclenchera l'action on le voit
bien que ce soit dans le monde la
société civile dans le monde économique
etc en général l'action quand elle se
déclenche elle est toujours à une étape
intermédiaire entre l'individu seul et
trop de monde où ça devient trop
compliqué de faire des choses
très bien merci donc en fait c'est c'est
la démonstration que la fresque du
climat avec son aspect collectif et
vraiment un bon moyen de sensibilité si
je reformule en gros il faut une
initiative il y a souvent une initiative
dans une action donc il y a une
initiative qui va avec une capacité
pédagogique de la personne qui porte
l'initiative et un groupe qui est pas
trop nombreux en face pour recevoir
l'initiative et embrayer dessus en gros
c'est comme ça que ça se passe alors
justement
sur la capacité pédagogique de
l'animateur ou de l'animatrice on est
souvent confronté à un biais cognitif
qu'on appelle de surconscience et je me
tourne vers Étienne là-dessus sur cette
question on peut rencontrer des
interlocuteurs enfin des participants
qui pensent déjà tout savoir vous avez
donné un nom à ce à ce biocognitif
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire deux
mots que j'ai inventé c'est un mot qui
était surtout en utilisant en anglais
et dans un petit livre que j'ai publié
au mois de juillet de l'année dernière
en voyant justement cette mise en scène
de la science et la recherche qui m'a
traumatisée je l'ai je l'ai écrit dans
le texte en définissant ce mot un peu
pédant
c'est l'ultra crépi d'arianisme c'est
une histoire de cordonnier c'est le
c'est une histoire qui racontait par
Pline l'Ancien et un jour il est allé
voir un grand peintre de l'époque qui
s'appelait appel et il s'est fait
accompagner par son cordonnier et le
cordonnier a vu que un des grands
tableaux d'appel représentant des
personnages
ces personnages avaient des sandales qui
étaient mal mal représenté Malte
pas conforme à ce que sont les sandales
dans la réalité donc le cordonnier s'est
permis de dire à appel les sandales ça
va pas et appelle à corriger en direct
il a corrigé le tableau pour que les
sandales soient tels que le cordonnier
avait dit qu'elle devait être et ça a
beaucoup flatté le cordonnier qui du
coup c'est en hardi et à critiqué aussi
la façon de peindre les toges
et là appelle a dit aux cordonniers
calmos
la compétence du cordonnier s'arrête à
la sandale
ce qui donne en latin Sutor né supra
crepidam donc l'ultra crépi d'arianisme
c'est le fait de parler au delà de ses
compétences ce qui est une très bonne
chose dans la vie publique je pense que
le lien social la vie démocratique elle
existe que chacun d'entre nous pratique
le trac et puis d'arianisme quand vous
allez au café avec vos amis et vous
parlez de tout y compris le sujet pour
lesquels vous n'avez pas un doctorat
donc la vie de la cité suppose qu'on
parle qu'on se sente autorisé à parler
de tout sauf que il y a des situations
notamment scientifiques ou il y en a qui
s'afflusent que d'autres et puis il y a
aussi des situations plus intéressantes
ou personne ne sait personne ne sait et
à ce moment-là la bonne attitude c'est
l'humilité or parfois quand personne ne
sait les gens arrogants font croire
qu'ils savent
c'est par exemple c'est tweet qu'on
voyait au début de la pandémie je ne
suis pas médecin mais je pense que
donc vous avouez votre incompétence de
médecin ce qui est honnête
et après vous délivrez une ordonnance
c'est louche voilà mais alors justement
il y a une chose qui est pire que le
trainisme c'est encore un mot un nom un
peu pédant c'est ce qu'on appelle lipsé
dixitisme
l'excès
lipsé dixitisme alors ça c'est du latin
c'est ipsé dixit le maître l'a dit
le maître l'a dit donc comme il a raison
c'est le maître je n'exerce plus mon
esprit critique
dans sa forme dégradée ça donne l'effet
gourou
l'effet gourou et vous choisissez la
personne qui fait autorité pour vous
et puis tout ce qu'elle dit vous le
buvez comme une parole d'évangile sans
jamais voir si ce qui est dit là est
vrai ou pas on a vu c'est un parallèle
encore possible entre le covid et le
climat en France on a eu notre Petit
Gourou
voilà
et puis pour ce qui est du
climatossepticisme on a eu aussi nos
petits gourous voilà on y comprend rien
nous mais ils disent que le chameau
climatique n'est pas dû à l'activité
humaine
on les croit
leurs arguments
dans les deux cas les arguments sur les
arguments de bon sens
de se ranger sous la coupe de l'opinion
on fait un sondage le 5 avril 2020 pour
savoir si tel médicament est efficace
contre le coronavirus on demande aux
gens est-ce que ce médicament est
efficace on leur demande même pas est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il est efficace
on leur demande de dire s'il est
efficace à une époque où personne ne
connaît la réponse puisque pour le
savoir faut des études statistiques que
personnel le temps de faire et bien 80%
des gens ont répondu oui ou non à cette
question et donc la question c'est la
vôtre c'est d'où vient notre promptitude
à nous déclarer expert à propos de
questions dont personne ne connaît là et
surtout comment lutter en tant
qu'animateur ou animatrice de la fresque
du climat face comment contourner cet
obstacle quand on est face à des gens
qui croient déjà tout savoir Jean-Marc
est-ce que vous avez
des astuces
c'est un travers qui pour moi est un
travers normal parce que ça représente
un gain de temps dans ce qu'on dans
l'envie de comprendre ce qui nous
entoure
dans un dans un des bouquins de
Sébastien Bollaert qui sur lequel moi
j'ai rien à dire sur la partie purement
neurologique j'ai envie de dire savoir
si ça vient d'ici ou de là ou de là où
je sais pas quoi dans la cervelle
m'intéresse qu'à moitié par contre il a
souligné que il y avait un facteur qui
était important chez nous qui était
d'accumuler de l'information parce que
c'était quelque chose qui renvoyait à
une époque ou avoir plus d'informations
sur l'environnement est un facteur de
survie comprendre c'est ce qui n'est de
passer c'était un tigre à dents de sabre
ou une libellule c'était quand même
effectivement important pour faire la
différence sur sur son propre destin
et donc comme on est des animaux
accumulatifs sur l'information tout ce
qui nous permet de gagner de
l'information plus rapidement est un
truc qui en général est confortable pour
nous etc et le processus qui vient
d'être décrit est en fait est un
processus qui au fond est un processus
de gain de temps c'est à dire ne pas
réfléchir et prendre pour argent
comptant ce qui a été dit par quelqu'un
d'autre la motivation intrinsèque de ce
truc là c'est qu'on gagne on pense
gagner du temps on se dit il y a
quelqu'un d'autre qui a réfléchit pour
moi etc et donc la bonne question c'est
pas tellement de lutter contre ça enfin
si il faut un peu lutter contre ça il
faut surtout à mon avis apprendre aux
gens des règles de processus pour qu'ils
comprennent à qui peut faire confiance
sur quoi
donc faire confiance à mon charcutier
sur la façon de faire du fromage de tête
c'est pas lui faire confiance sur la
façon de guérir le covid donc tout le
monde a un domaine de compétence tout le
monde sait la question tout à l'heure
d'étage et des sandales tout le monde
n'est pas compétent surtout et en fait
la question qui est importante et je
pense que la fresque du climat peut
servir à ça c'est faire comprendre les
règles de processus qui permettent
d'accorder sa confiance à quelqu'un sur
un sujet et de comprendre que ça doit se
limiter à ce sujet et que sur dos et
housse et en gros comprendre rapidement
comment est-ce qu'on fixe une limite
entre ce sur quoi la personne est
compétente et ce sur quoi elle est pas
compétente par exemple dans le domaine
du changement climatique il y a un truc
que font tous les journalistes parce que
il manque de temps et une fois qu'ils
ont quelqu'un sous la main ils vont lui
faire la totale c'est passé de la
définition du problème à ce qu'il faut
faire pour régler le problème bon il se
trouve que c'est juste pas les mêmes
donc quand on demande à Hervé le truc où
Jean jauge elle de définir le problème
ils font partie des gens compétents pour
ça si on leur demande s'il faut faire
plutôt des éoliennes ou limiter la
taille des voitures ils sont pas que
c'est pas l'heure de du tout leur
domaine de compétence sauf que
journaliste qui passe par là il se dit
bon ben j'en tiens et ce qui intéresse
mes auditeurs c'est d'avoir le bouquin
du début à la fin introduction
développement conclusion donc PAF bon et
c'est difficile à ce moment-là de dire
je ne sais pas donc il y a des gens qui
y arrivent il y a des gens qui y
arrivent pas c'est difficile et donc le
et donc c'est vraiment ça pour moi qui
est important donc dans la fresque du
climat alors ça par contre je suis pas
sûr de l'avoir vu aujourd'hui dans les
messages qui passent autour donc moi
j'ai fait le jeu j'ai pas vu passer mais
je pense que c'est pas très compliqué de
le rajouter et de faire comprendre que
il y a une règle de processus alors moi
par exemple ma réponse au
climato-sceptique elle est avec une
règle de processus je commence toujours
par donner la règle de processus avant
de donner la réponse sur le fond les
revues scientifiques avec exactement
donc la règle de processus c'est la
réfutation par les pairs tout argument
qui n'a pas passé ce premier filtre
c'est même pas la peine de regarder
derrière bon c'est pas une vérité
absolue il y a des trucs réfutés par les
pères qui peuvent être des conneries et
il y a d'autres domaines que la physique
et la biologie ou la réfutation par les
Pères n'est absolument pas une garantie
je veux parler de l'économie par exemple
non c'est pas parce que un modèle avec
un seul consommateur un seul produit et
des fonctions d'utilité a été réfutées
par les pairs que il raconte des trucs
intelligents donc c'est pas une règle
absolue mais c'est quand même un premier
filtre
qui est une qui est une nécessité bon
il se trouve moi c'est un truc que je
dis souvent que dans le domaine de des
sciences du climat je n'ai jamais vu un
argument climato-sceptique je dis bien
pas un qui est passé la rampe de la
publication dans une revue à comité de
lecture et qui n'est pas été réfuté par
le même canal et autrement il n'a pas un
je vais chercher il y a pas s'il y a des
gens joueurs je viens prendre les paris
à la sortie de la salle vous en
trouverez pas donc cette règle de
processus
est quelque chose qui va aider les gens
et ça ça va rester cohérent avec leur
souhait de gagner du temps dans
l'acquisition de l'information parce que
c'est une règle rapide à appliquer à
savoir si ça a été publié ou pas publié
c'est assez rapide à appliquer comme
règle et ça et quelque part c'est même
parfois plus plus rapide à appliquer
comme règle que de rentrer dans le
détail de pourquoi est-ce que dans le
passé la température a pu précéder le
CO2 et maintenant c'est l'inverse donner
l'explication de ce truc là c'est plus
long que de donner juste la règle de
processus
donc le le la voie de contournement à
cette à cet effet quelqu'un qui a dit un
truc qui me paraît frapper au coin du
bon sens du coup tout ce qui suit
derrière je vais le prendre dans le même
paquet c'est la règle de processus et je
le redis une même personne peut très
bien dans un domaine dire des choses
sensées et puis ensuite dans un autre
domaine dire absolument n'importe quoi
parce que elle va déborder de sa règle
de processus et elle peut même le faire
alors même que c'était pas son intention
je redis quelqu'un qui ne sait pas dire
non un journaliste qui lui dit qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire et qui n'a pas le
courage de lui dire à ce moment-là bah
écoutez je suis désolé c'est pas mon
rayon
peut très bien se laisser entraîner dans
des choses qui sont
approximatives fausses etc on étudier
non vérifié enfin voilà c'est c'est ça
va très vite voilà donc là
je réinsiste une troisième fois mais
pour moi vraiment c'est ça le c'est ça
qui fait la compétence de quelqu'un et
en fait c'est ça aussi qui fait qu'on
peut être vulgarisateur sans être
chercheur on peut être vulgarisateur à
ce moment il suffit de vulgariser ce qui
a passé cette règle de processus et à ce
moment normalement on limite la quantité
d'un riz qu'on raconte
enfin en tout cas dans la définition
scientifique du dossier climatique dans
ce qu'il faut faire ça relève de
processus qui sont tout autre
donc là si on a l'occasion je pourrais
éventuellement parler de ce qui se passe
au chiffre Jacques mais le le sur la
partie juste compréhension et des faits
je pense que c'est vraiment cette règle
qu'il faut avoir en tête
ok
il y a un autre biais qui intéresse
aussi les fresqueurs qui est un peu
l'inverse qui est que quand on est quand
on est devenu expert ou vulgarisateur on
peut avoir tendance à surestimer le
niveau des autres est-ce que vous avez
vous-même déjà rencontré
ce problème parce que finalement on peut
rapidement perdre son auditoire au bout
de phrases et puis enfin Cédric raconte
souvent que que quand il a commencé à
faire je sais pas où il est voilà que
quand il a commencé à faire la fresque
du climat il parlait à son entourage des
gaz à effet de serre c'est ça Cédric et
en fait il s'est aperçu que personne ne
savait ce que c'était quoi
pour se rendre compte qu'on est
incompétent faut devenir compétent donc
au début on a confiance on arrogant puis
à mesure qu'on travaille on découvre que
le problème est plus compliqué qu'est-ce
qu'on avait imaginé on baisse en
arrogance alors même qu'on croit en
compétences et quand on a vu le
réalisateur souvent c'est par passion
donc on est passionné par certaines
questions
l'interprétation de la physique
quantique la question de la flèche du
temps en physique statistique etc et
comment on est passionné
on pense que tout le monde est passionné
et on découvre en effet que non et que
ces connaissances qui sont le résultat
d'une passion ne sont pas du tout
partagés et
c'est un équipe difficile à trouver
parce que si vous prenez les choses à un
niveau trop élémentaire
vous pouvez donner l'impression au
public que vous l'infantilisez voilà et
si vous les prenez si vous prenez un
niveau trop
il aura l'impression d'être
finalement exclu du champ de votre
discours donc c'est assez difficile mais
mais et c'est un vrai piège parce que
quand on fait la fresque du climat
certains animateurs et animatrices
demandent avant
aux participants d'essayer d'évaluer
leur niveau pour savoir à quel à quel
niveau eux-mêmes ils vont se mettre et
souvent enfin moi j'ai souvent eu
l'expérience de gens qui disent ne rien
savoir et qui en fait sont déjà les plus
compétents du groupe et des gens qui se
disent donnent neuf huit ou neuf en
connaissance climatique qui en fait ne
savent quasiment rien donc
ça démontre une chose c'est que en fait
l'ignorance
c'est la grande affaire des savants
c'est à dire
savoir qu'on ignore
c'est savoir déjà tout ce qu'on ignore
pas
donc l'ignorance et l'affaire des
savants et non pas désignards parce
qu'un ignare ne sait même pas qui
l'ignore et en fait croire savoir c'est
plus dangereux qu'il n'y aurait
et donc pour revenir d'ailleurs sur ce
que disait à l'instant Jean-Marc avec
lequel je suis pleinement d'accord
normalement quand un scientifique parle
il devrait toujours dire nous nous
savons que c'est pas lui qui c'est
l'ensemble des gens qui ont discuté des
mêmes questions qui se sont parfois
disputés mais à la fin si les choses se
sont bien passées ils parviennent
ensemble à faire parler un bout du réel
et ils sont d'accord sur ce qu'il faut
dire donc ils disent nous savons que
et ensuite il pourrait ajouter et nous
nous demandons si
vous voyez cette phrase en deux parties
sépare la science de la recherche nous
savons que c'est la science nous
demandons si c'est la recherche
simplement quand vous êtes à la
télévision
en réponse à une question d'un
journaliste vous répondez je ne sais pas
ou mieux nous ne savons pas nous ne
savons pas
une partie de l'opinion va considérer
que vous êtes un mauvais chercheur
c'est quelqu'un qui répond à toutes les
questions un bon chercheur pardon c'est
quelqu'un qui répond à toutes les
questions c'est un savant
et du coup vous serez médiatiquement
détrôné
par des gens qui ne disent jamais je ne
sais pas
et donc je pense que il faut apprendre à
parler d'une façon qui fasse la part des
choses ce qui est sûr collectivement
et ce qui n'est pas sûr sinon on crée de
la confusion et cette confusion est à
mon avis le plus grand ennemi de la de
la pédagogie j'ajoute juste une chose
qui peut permettre je suis tombé par
hasard sur un texte de Thomas hopes qui
s'appelle le levier le Léviathan que
vous connaissez il dit un truc qui est
qui était donc vrai à l'époque puisqu'il
le dit mais qui est encore plus vrai
aujourd'hui il dit en gros que notre
notre
passion est sélective parmi il y a des
vérités
qu'on ne conteste pas soit parce qu'on
les ignore soit parce qu'elles nous sont
indifférentes
et il parle des vérités de la géométrie
la somme des ondes d'un triangle c'est
180 degrés
ça gêne personne ça ne menace les
intérêts de personnes ça ne contrecar
les ambitions de personnes donc ce sont
des vérités qui ne sont pas contestées
mais il dit si ces théorème de géométrie
nous dérangeait
vous dérangez le pouvoir de quelques-uns
on organiserait des bûcher des lits de
géométrie
ça c'est l'affaire du climat c'est à
dire que vous voyez bien qu'il y a des
vérités de sciences qui sont contestées
par personne
quand on a découvert le boson de Higgs
en 2012 ou bien les ondes
gravitationnelles en 2016 est-ce que
vous avez vu des livres en librairie
intitulée ma vérité sur le boson de
Higgs
ma vérité sur les ondes
gravitationnelles non personne
n'est écrit parce qu'en fait le boson de
X on s'en fout
les ondes gravitationnelles on s'en fout
mais quand les thèses climatiques va des
climatologues sont devenus difficiles à
contester
donc très dérangeant
on a vu des livres
ma vérité sur la planète
autrement dit nous ne contestons que les
vérités scientifiques qui nous dérangent
c'est à dire qu'ils nous oblige à
changer nos modes de vie à réfléchir à
notre situation
à tenir compte des leçons du passé
visible dans le présent pour modifier
notre vision du futur etc et ça c'est un
exercice très difficile qui du coup
provoque des résistances qui sont pour
vous des obstacles
merci
Jean-Marc voulait dire quelque chose
là-dessus pour rebondir sur est-ce que
ça vous est déjà arrivé de dire je ne
sais pas Jean-Marc
mais à mon avis oui bien sûr
sur la question de du biais de confiance
sur on a affaire des gens qui savent il
y a une petite astuce ce qui consiste à
essayer de parler à plein de gens qui ne
nous ressemblent pas
parce que ça nous ramène sur terre
parler à l'occasion j'en sais rien moi
au commerçants du marché au chauffeur de
bus à l'employé de la gare enfin je vais
regarder à des gens qu'on voilà
parce que c'est un très bon exercice
salutaire voilà il faut il faut il faut
éviter le communautarisme nos fréquenter
que des gens qui nous ressemblent c'est
ça c'est un travers pas toujours facile
à éviter
dans lequel je tombe moi-même de temps
en temps mais voilà comme j'ai quelques
cheveux blancs maintenant je sais que il
faut éviter de faire ce genre de truc
et il faut jamais hésiter à dire je ne
sais pas
même si je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit Étienne sur le fait que de temps en
temps face à un journaliste alors que ce
soit dérangeant ces déranges en face aux
journalistes parce que ça lui fait
perdre du temps parce que du coup il a
besoin de deux personnes au lieu d'une
je suis pas complètement convaincu que
face à l'audience soit si dérangeant que
ça parce que tous les gens qui écoutent
se sont retrouvés eux-mêmes dans une
situation où un jour ils ont dû à défaut
de le dire au moins se dire que il ne
savait pas donc dire je ne sais pas bah
voilà où est-ce que tu as mis les clés
je ne sais pas
tous de temps en temps
[Musique]
donc tous on a dû dire un jour je ne
sais pas donc je enfin en tout cas moi
ça me pose strictement aucun problème de
dire je ne sais pas
et on peut en profiter à l'occasion pour
expliquer pourquoi on ne sait pas
et à ce moment ça renforce souvent la
crédibilité sur ce qu'on dit savoir
et justement Jean-Marc quand vous
adressez hors du cercle des gens qu'on
côtoie habituellement
les exemples que vous avez donné est-ce
que vous avez déjà eu des réactions qui
vous ont déstabilisé
les réactions
en matière de je sais je ne sais pas je
vous dirai pas qui c'est parce que c'est
vraiment [ __ ]
il y a quelques mois j'ai discuté avec
un des ministres du gouvernement actuel
qui m'a qui ne savait pas
enfin exactement qui croyait que la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'un pays
modifiait le climat du pays en question
c'est pas très loin de Sarkozy et de son
climat il a trop joué le trou dans la
couche d'ozone pas très très loin voilà
et alors
voilà donc c'est c'est pour dire que il
y a des tas de gens avec lesquels on
peut discuter et on est ramené sur terre
en ce qui concerne c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un ministre donc il faut
pas le vexer mais il faut quand même
juste pas mon sujet je le dis pas qui
c'est en public parce que je pense que
ça serait contre-productif parce que
braquer quelqu'un c'est toujours
contre-productif je cherche pas de
savoir qui c'est je cherche à savoir ce
que vous avez fait rien
j'ai pris note je lui ai dit très
calmement c'est pas le cas
d'accord je lui ai très calmement que
comme l'atmosphère se brassait en un à
deux ans et que le temps de résidence
d'un surplus de CO2 dans l'air c'était
des milliers d'années bah que non
c'était pas comme ça que ça marchait
mais faut pas perdre son calme et il
faut pas etc donc quelque part il y a eu
courage de me faire une confidence même
s'il n'a pas voulu
sur quelque chose qui est quand même un
point important dans la définition du
problème mais il est pas le seul il y a
un sondage qui est paru aux États-Unis
il y a quelques mois on avait posé la
question à la population alors on a beau
dire que les Américains sont des abrutis
et les Français des gens très
intelligents je pense qu'en France on
serait pas loin du même résultat on
avait demandé aux Américains quel était
le temps de retour à la normale après
arrêt des émissions dans deux cas de
figure qui était CO2 et particules fines
et les sonder ont donné la même réponse
dans les deux cas de figure c'est-à-dire
de l'ordre du siècle
ils étaient donc du coup beaucoup plus
près de la vérité pour le CO2 pour les
particules fines puisque les particules
fines si on arrête d'émettre demain
matin je dis bien la totalité des
particules fines dans le monde on attend
quelques semaines quelques mois et c'est
comme si on n'avait jamais rien fait
alors que en ce qui concerne le CO2 spa
exactement la voilà donc c'est c'est je
pense que c'est très fréquent donc
j'en reviens à la question qui est-ce
que ça m'est arrivé d'être déstabilisé
oui mais je suis plus déstabilisé par
les intentions que par les lacunes dans
la compréhension du problème parce que
je sais très bien que la compréhension
du problème c'est compliqué
que ça renvoie à des notions que
certains n'ont jamais vu pendant leur
cours
il y a plein de gens qui sortent du
système éducatif sans savoir ce que
c'est que le rayonnement infrarouge donc
ils ont entendu éventuellement parler
parce qu'on leur a parlé à la télé des
caméras infrarouges ils ont bien vu
qu'on voyait les gens la nuit avec ça
enfin ils savent toujours pas ce que
c'est qu'un rayonnement infrarouge donc
le donc ça mais ça à la limite à force
de pédagogie et surtout quand on est en
face de gens qu'on arrive à intéresser
c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive à exciter leur
curiosité on finit par y arriver ce qui
est beaucoup plus difficile et beaucoup
plus déstabilisant c'est quand les gens
une fois qu'ils ont compris le problème
tombent dans une espèce de désarroi de
constat d'impuissance de de ne rester ni
quelquefois d'agressivité en fait etc
donc en gros c'est la réaction à la
compréhension du problème qui est aussi
entre on est tous foutus c'est de la
faute de ses abrutis je vais leur couper
la tête etc et ça ça peut provoquer des
situations déstabilisantes parce que là
on est plus dans la position de la
personne qui fait passer une
connaissance
on est dans la position du psy qui doit
canaliser des émotions ça a strictement
rien à voir en termes de posture ça a
strictement rien à voir en termes de
compétences tu vois je suis pas du tout
sûr de les avoir et donc ça ça peut être
une situation qui est beaucoup plus
déstabilisante que la situation dans
laquelle on doit entre guillemets se
battre sur des sujets de compréhension
du problème qui sont pour moi des sujets
en fait beaucoup plus facile que les
sujets de gestion des émotions parce que
ça ça renvoie à des situations
personnelles qu'on connaît pas toujours
ça enfin voilà c'est c'est toujours
qu'on connaît jamais en fait d'ailleurs
c'est un peu la bascule dans la fresque
du climat quand on passe de des cartes
au débrief et je vais finir avec une
remarque c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles très égoïstement
je fuis les audiences de cheveux blancs
et je préfère de très loin les audiences
de jeunes parce que la canalisation des
émotions chez les jeunes est beaucoup
plus facile à faire parce que c'est des
gens qui pensent encore qui peuvent
changer les choses c'est quand même
agréable c'est des gens qui peuvent
encore quelque chose
ce qui est aussi plus agréable
c'est des c'est des gens qui sont moins
prisonniers de leur rente tout à l'heure
on parlait de là en fait je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec Etienne tous les
climato-sceptiques c'est des gens qui
quelque part comprennent qui vont perdre
une rente si on accepte que le problème
soit réel une rente de réputation une
rente économique une rampe de confort
moral n'importe laquelle mais ils ont
tous une rampe à perdre et c'est pour ça
qu'en fait ils sont climato-sceptiques
et et voilà donc c'est c'est clair que
c'est le sujet qui pour moi est vraiment
déstabilisant dans cette affaire c'est
la gestion des émotions
merci
je voudrais qu'on passe à une autre
séquence qui sont les vecteurs du
message on a parlé de de ce ministre qui
est visiblement n'était pas encore tout
à fait à la hauteur
les vecteurs de la sensibilisation
enseignement média association
scientifique ont-ils tous un rôle à
jouer ce que je viens de citer et
finalement
lesquels lesquelles prioriser
enseignement média association
scientifiques
c'est mon tour mais c'est pas ma
compétence
ce qu'a dit Jean-Marc est important
c'est à dire que la bonne pédagogie
c'est celle qui s'est confrontée à
toutes sortes de public enfin moi j'ai
jamais autant appris en matière de
pédagogie expérience pédagogique qu'on a
leur donner des cours en prison parce
qu'en prison vous allez faire des
populations qui sont contrairement à ce
qu'on pense extrêmement hétérogène il y
a des gens très cultivés d'autres pas du
tout il y a des illettrés et en trouvant
le moyen de parler à ces gens très
différents on apprend à utiliser
quelques ressorts qui sont pas du tout
ceux qu'on utilise quand on donne un
cours à des étudiants par exemple
et donc moi je dirais que quand vous
vous adressez
en tant que vulgaire vulgarisateur un
public vous savez jamais très bien qui
va vous lire et qui vous avez percuté et
donc définir le public comme étant un
ensemble de cibles disparate auquel
chaque discours devrait s'adapter plus
ou moins ça me semble être une une
démarche pas très
donc une anecdote il y a quelques années
il y avait une émission à France Culture
dans cette émission et notre travail
c'était de il y avait un biologiste un
physicien une personne des sciences
sociales etc on devait expliquer un
article récent paru dans une revue
scientifique de très haut niveau donc
matcher etc et l'un d'entre nous
choisissez l'article et puis l'expliquer
aux auditeurs
et si c'était un niveau
très haut c'est-à-dire moi je comprenais
même pas ce que disait mes
collaborateurs
biologistes ou autres et donc la chaîne
a décidé d'arrêter les missions
en disant c'est trop
et on a reçu
un sac postal de courrier
et en le lisant on a vu qu'on était
écouté par les agriculteurs
par des gens qui en fait n'avaient pas
le niveau scolaire a priori prérequis
mais qui aimait entendre cette musique
là
et il y avait pas eu d'enquête spéciale
de l'audimat on n'aurait pas imaginé
qu'on était écouté par les agriculteurs
donc cette idée de cible tout ça ça me
ça me parle au micro en fait ma question
c'était pas tellement sur la cible mais
sur qui doit se charger du message et
notamment vous êtes scientifique on voit
les climatologues parfois partager un
petit peu sortir de leur laboratoire et
prendre la parole en public puis se
faire parfois attaquer en leur dit mais
vous n'êtes pas dans votre rôle il y a
un énorme débat dans la communauté des
climatologues je parle de celle que je
connais qui m'installer à Saclay dans un
laboratoire qui s'appelle LFCE
il y a ceux qui disent non on est des
scientifiques notre boulot c'est de
publier
et d'autres qui disent dans des revues
scientifiques d'autres qui disent mais
non ce qu'on découvre est tellement
grave qu'on doit faire du militantisme
et il n'y a pas de position juste a
priori c'est à dire que chacun doit le
faire comme il le sent il y en a même
qui a abandonne la caractère la carrière
de chercheur pour devenir des pédagogues
des lanceurs d'alerte on pourrait dire
mais je voudrais insister sur le fait
que être climatologue c'est un métier
extrêmement spécial parce que d'habitude
quand on est scientifique on éprouve une
joie de la découverte on est content de
faire une découverte
les physiciens des particules quand ils
trouvent une particule ils sont aux
anges
les climatologues quand ils font une
découverte
en général elle aggrave leur
connaissance déjà acquise
il y a même des cellules psychologiques
pour climatologues
donc c'est un rapport à la connaissance
qui est assez nouveau on découvre des
mauvaises nouvelles qui apparaissent par
le biais de nouvelles connaissances ou
de découverte combien de faire et ça
c'est ça l'air adoda mais en fait ça ça
coupe le pied de l'idée même de progrès
puisque
croire au progrès c'est configurer le
futur d'une façon crédible et attractive
le futur sera mieux que le présent et
l'image qu'on s'en fait est crédible
parce que elle est cautionnée par la
science et la science qui est le moteur
de l'idée de progrès
mais aujourd'hui quand vous écoutez des
scientifiques qui travaillent non pas
sur les trous noirs ou les particules
élémentaires qui eux continuent à vous
faire rêver c'est pas des scientifiques
qui travaillent sur le climat la
biodiversité la pollution la réfraction
des ressources eux quand ils parlent du
futur ils disent des choses qui en
général sont catastrophiques donc quand
c'est crédible c'est pas attractif et
quand c'est attractif c'est pas crédible
et donc lassise même qui permet de
fonder l'idée de progrès et détruite par
le fait que les scientifiques nous
lancent des messages qui sont très
anxiogènes et ça ça rend la pédagogie
encore une fois
plus délicate parce qu'elle ne peut elle
ne peut plus se baser uniquement comme
on le fait en physique par exemple sur
l'enthousiasme la connaissance sur la
joie intellectuelle que produit la
connaissance et c'est
une un autre argument pour dire que
votre tâche est impossible donc
excitante
merci Jean-Marc sur les vecteurs
l'enseignement c'est un des
un des chevaux cheval de bataille des
chevaux de bataille des chiffres project
est-ce que tu est-ce que vous pouvez
sortir de vous démasquer est-ce que je
peux pardon en dire deux mots
parler de ce que fait le Shift pour pour
que les enjeux climat et biodiversité
soit prise en compte dans la formation
de l'enseignement supérieur
alors la question du changement
climatique elle touche tous les
compartiments de la société chacun
d'entre nous donc effectivement on s'y
project on pense mais je pense qu'à la
fresque du client on pensait exactement
la même chose que il faut faire partager
la compréhension des enjeux et
faire naître le débat sur qu'est-ce
qu'on fait maintenant
auprès du plus grand nombre alors les
moyens de diffusion en masse de
l'information il y en a trois
il y a la formation initiale il y a les
médias alors dans les médias maintenant
il y a un ensemble protéiforme parce que
quand j'étais petit il y a très très
longtemps les médias c'était les
journaux la télé il y avait pas Internet
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire toute personne qui
fait un bout de chaîne Youtube ou un
bout de site internet peut rentrer de
fait dans les médias
et donc c'est c'est devenu
par exemple thinkerview à mon avis plus
d'audience que la quasi-totalité des
émissions de LCI de la Chaîne
parlementaire ou de voilà donc c'est
c'est ça c'est un peu déplacé mais en
gros les médias et puis la formation
continue donc il y a trois il y a trois
vecteurs de diffusion en masse on peut
pas se permettre dans les séances de
côté parce que l'essentiel de la
population actuelle elle est sortie du
système de l'enseignement initial donc
si on dit c'est juste une affaire
d'enseignement initial et ben on zappe
80% des gens qui quand même pas mort
demain matin et donc on peut pas dire
ces gens-là ne vont voilà dans le cadre
de la formation continue c'est pas
nécessairement très facile de faire
rentrer cette question là donc quelque
part la fresque du climat c'est de la
formation continue c'est exactement ça
dure je pense qu'une partie des
entreprises le prenne exactement comme
ça
le prennent comme un quelque chose qui
rentre dans la formation continue donc
pour moi c'est là dedans que que vous
êtes capable de vous inscrire c'est
aussi un outil pour la formation
initiale parce qu'il y a aussi des
établissements enseignements qui s'en
servent mais je veux dire c'est aussi un
vecteur important pour la formation
continue et enfin il y a des médias
alors les médias ils ont leur propre
règle de fonctionnement et en
particulier ils en ont une qui est
absolument capitale qu'il faut bien
avoir en tête qui est que il aucun média
ne cherche à faire fuir son audience
aucun donc ce qu'a dit ça se rapproche
de ce que vient de dire Étienne sur le
fait que découvrir des nouvelles choses
en matière de changement climatique
c'est souvent à prendre une mauvaise
nouvelle de plus
et
fournir des mauvaises nouvelles à son
lectorat c'est difficilement compatible
avec ce que souhaite la régie
publicitaire ou même ce que souhaite la
façon de fonctionner des gestionnaires
de médias même quand leurs médias ne
dépend pas des recettes publicitaires
par exemple la démagogie de l'audience
frappe tout autant Radio France que TF1
pas de différence pour ce que j'en
connais donc le il y a un sujet il y a
une barrière à l'entrée très forte de
ces sujets là dans les médias c'est que
ils sont difficilement compatibles avec
le fonctionnement même d'un média qui
est de ne pas faire fuir les gens dont
il s'occupe après il y a d'autres
limites dans les médias
bien connaître puisqu'elle y est passé
qui sont la spécialisation qui rend
difficile de traiter un problème
transverse changement climatique c'est
un problème transverse et quand les gens
sont organisés avec un secteur
économique un secteur automobile un
secteur chien écrasé et un secteur
politique très compliqué de faire
rentrer un sujet de transverse et puis
il y a un sujet de compétence des
journalistes eux-mêmes et par ailleurs
de prétention des journalistes eux-mêmes
là je vais la nommer les assalamer a
reçu hier ou avant-hier et demeurant
Tintin et Tintin Tyrant les oliviers et
Blanchères
et elle a dit si je n'ai pas mal entendu
dans ce rapport passionnant dit-elle
pour introduire un rapport de 500 pages
sortis la veille donc évidemment il n'a
pas lu une page donc elle dans telle
quand elle dit dans ce rapport
passionnant c'est quand vous dites qu'un
roman est passionnant en général vous
l'avez lu quoi que vous disiez qu'un
roman est passionnant qu'un bouquin
détient des passionnant si vous l'avez
pas lu
et bien
laisser croire là donc là c'est un
mensonge dire ce document passionnant
c'est implicitant un mensonge donc il y
a plein de problèmes dans les médias qui
rendent très difficile la transmission
de l'information par ailleurs les
journalistes sont des gens entre
guillemets ordinaires donc quand ils
deviennent journalistes ou quand ils
sont journalistes ils sont sensibles
comme tout le monde au widir dans tous
les domaines dans lesquels ils
travaillent quand vous rentrez à la
rédaction de France Info le premier truc
que vous voyez c'est une pile de
journaux haute comme moi donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils arrêtent pas de
se copier les uns les autres en fait
leur première source d'inspiration c'est
ce qu'a dit le voisin c'est pour ça que
les sujets tournent en boucle
donc le donc il y a plein de limites
intrinsèques dans tous les vecteurs de
diffusion de l'information à l'éducation
nationale il y a une limite intrinsèque
c'est que on forme pas sans former les
enseignants
et dans le système de l'éducation
nationale vous pouvez pas remplacer les
enseignants sont pas vacataire donc vous
pouvez pas les remplacer par des gens
qui sont capables de faire
l'enseignement en disant bah eux ils
sont pas bons donc non vous les formez
je dis pas que c'est bon ou mauvais je
dis c'est juste une c'est comme ça voilà
c'est long faut trouver les bons
formateurs
quand vous leur donnez des outils qui
sont les manuels scolaires il faut
trouver les gens qui vont bien faire les
manuels scolaires et quand vous regardez
en tout ça c'est les points de détails
quand vous regardez qui fait les manuels
scolaires et comment et qui vérifie ce
qu'il y a dans les manuels scolaires bah
c'est une vraie question bien comment ça
marche mais en tout cas ça marche pas
bien parce que on trouve des conneries
grosses comme moi et même deux fois
grosse comme moi dans les manuels
scolaires sur les sujets de climat et
d'énergie et qui et qui ressemble au
widir que vous avez trouvé la veille
dans le Figaro ou sur France Inter donc
il y a il y a un vrai sujet de savoir où
est la buse projection quand on veut
changer le système c'est c'est compliqué
donc tout le monde doit y participer
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien
dit parce que c'est à ce moment que les
frais de problèmes pratiquent commencent
encore une fois si on veut faire droit à
ces sujets les journées ne faisant que
24 heures il faut nécessairement évacuer
autre chose parce que on va pas faire
des programmes pour que les gens
apprennent le jour et la nuit la nuit
les gens dorment enfin ils sont priés de
dormir donc si on se met à donner
beaucoup de place à des sujets nouveaux
bah il faut savoir qu'est-ce qu'on
évacue dans les sujets anciens est-ce
qu'on fait un peu moins de géographie un
peu moins d'histoire un peu moins de
latin un peu moins d'anglais un peu
moins de physique
et à chaque fois on fait gueuler
quelqu'un non mais à chaque fois on fait
gueuler quelqu'un ah non on va quand
même pas toucher à ça bon donc c'est des
sujets compliqués partout et tout le
temps alors une fois que j'ai dit ça ça
explique pourquoi aussi project on a
commencé par s'attaquer au sujet les
plus faciles
donc les sujets les plus faciles c'est
l'enseignement supérieur là où il y a
que des vacataires c'est-à-dire les
grandes écoles parce que c'est là qu'on
a à faire aux gens qui sont les plus
facilement atteignables en termes de
connaissances préalable
et avec un corps enseignant qu'on peut
changer très facilement je veux dire moi
je suis vacataire Robin on peut me de
demain matin me dire ben écoute on t'a
assez vu maintenant on va changer le
programme on va plus faire ce que tu
fais on va faire un truc sur les plans
vertes dehors on va prendre quelqu'un
qui sait dire quelque chose sur les
plantes vertes c'est très facile à faire
très rapide c'est très etc donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a commencé par la première
marche de l'escalier celle qui était la
plus facile et il faut aller jusqu'à la
dernière la dernière c'est toutes
l'éducation nationale mais donc ça veut
dire un énorme programme de formation
continue pour les enseignants parce que
sauf erreur de ma part je crois que des
enseignants dans le système éducatif
français on doit en avoir de l'ordre du
million donc c'est pas une petite
population on va pas faire ça en 35
secondes donc il y a un dispositif à
mettre en place pour ça
auquel vous pouvez participer soit dit
en passant parce que voilà et je vais
finir sur juste une anecdote ici il y a
une grosse dizaine d'années j'ai fait
brièvement partie d'un comité d'experts
de la Fondation Hélène MacArthur en
Grande-Bretagne dont qui a 10 fois le
budget de la FNH en France et dont le la
mission est de faire du matériel
pédagogique pour le bon d'enseignant
anglais donc en fait ils ont dit là il y
a un point de blocage qui est la qualité
du matériel pédagogique qu'on donne aux
enseignants pour qu'ils soient capable
de parler correctement des sujets
environnementaux et donc leur seule
mission c'est de faire ce genre de
choses donc en fait il se substitue on
attend et au Hatier en faisant des
manuels qu'il considèrent comme étant ou
du matériel pédagogique qu'il considère
comme étant en raccord avec les faits et
utilisant des ressorts pédagogiques qui
permettent de parler à peu près
n'importe qui
merci
juste quelques mots sur les publics
cibles du message donc Étienne Klein
vous disiez que pour vous il y avait pas
un public parce que souvent on peut se
demander par qui commençait les citoyens
les politiques les entreprises les
financiers alors je repasserai la parole
à Jean-Marc après parce que au chiffre
vous avez bien défini votre cible mais
je voudrais d'abord entendre Etienne
Klein sur son pédagogie sur le climat je
me sens pas autorisé à le faire je suis
plutôt du côté des récepteurs mais
pour ce qui me concerne je me suis
intéressé à un premier public et qui
était les philosophes tout simplement
parce que il y a des mots qui sont
communs ou de disciplines je parle de la
physique et de la philosophie par
exemple le mot de temps c'est un mot qui
utilise les physiciens et un mot qui
utilise les philosophes
donc moi je me suis posé des questions
très naïve est-ce que quand un physicien
parle du temps il parle de la même chose
qu'un philosophe qui parle du temps
si la réponse est non il parle de choses
différentes pourquoi c'est le même mot
et si au contraire on considère qu'il
parle de la même chose
une autre question qui apparaissent
est-ce qui disent les mêmes choses de
cette même chose
et la réponse évidemment non Einstein ne
parle pas comme idyer et donc à qui
j'accorde du crédit
et donc moi mon premier travail ça a été
de dire j'ai d'imaginer ce que diraient
les équations de la physique si elle
pouvait parler du temps pour le dire
dans le langage dans un langage que
puisse
comprendre les philosophes qui
s'intéressent autant pour qu'ils
nourrissent leur pensée de philosophe
des résultats positifs obtenus par la
physique des marches passionnantes
complètement inutiles puisque c'est
inutile que c'est pas passionnant
le temps a été donné l'an dernier à
l'agrégation de philosophie c'était le
sujet
et les livres que devaient lire les
candidats d'agrégation la liste est
publiée c'est Aristote Saint-Augustin
Kant Heidegger mais à long Ponti Bergson
ou serbe
Einstein non Newton non Boltzman non et
donc on continue à faire comme si le
temps était une question que la
philosophie pouvait traiter de façon
autonome à partir de son propre passé
ensuite
si je devais choisir un public pour la
vulgarisation en général ce serait en
effet les enseignants puisque les
enseignants
ils parlent aux élèves donc s'ils disent
des bêtises elles sont kyste dans la
culture commune donc il faut les former
simplement ils sont soumis à des
injonctions de toutes sortes de
catégories de gens
ils ont complètement dépassés par
exemple on peut être enseignant en
physique sans être capable de dire
comment on a su que l'atome existe
on peut être enseignant en physique sans
être capable de dire comment on a su que
la terre était ronde
et donc vouloir enseigner l'histoire des
sciences pour que tout le monde
comprenne comment la Suisse qu'on sait
c'est impossible d'abord parce qu'on n'a
pas les enseignants capables de le faire
et d'autre part parce que l'histoire des
sciences c'est beaucoup trop compliqué
donc moi je pense que une technique
c'est d'expliquer une fois par an aux
élèves de tous les niveaux du primaire
jusqu'au cycle universitaire de raconter
sans que ce soit noté pour qu'il y ait
pas de de
sentiment que c'est soi-même qui est
jugé par la note qu'on aura
simplement te raconter en détail
l'histoire d'une découverte
la vraie histoire pas la légende on
raconte aussi l'histoire de ceux qui ont
perdu la bataille qui avait peut-être de
très bons arguments simplement ces
arguments étaient éliminés par une
donnée par une observation par une
expérience et ça permettrait de prendre
conscience
non pas dans les scientifiques il y a
aucun scientifique qui soit objectif il
y a aucun scientifique qui soit
complètement indépendant qui aucun
scientifique et qui n'est pas de
croyance qui n'est pas des biais
cognitifs ça n'existe pas donc ce qu'on
demande aux scientifiques c'est pas de
sortir de la condition humaine pour
devenir pour parce qu'ils auraient subi
une cure de désintéressement
qu'il est prémunéré contre tous les
travers cognitifs que nous pouvons avoir
c'est là que je rejoins Jean-Marc ce
qu'on demande un scientifique c'est
c'est simplement d'être honnête honnête
dans un sens très particulier c'était
une fois qu'on a obtenu un résultat
parce qu'on s'est posé une question et
qu'on a fait de la recherche de le
présenter de le présenter à d'autres
personnes qui se sont posées la même
question ou qui ont fait des travaux
similaires
pour recueillir leurs critique
et ces personnes m'ont peut-être qu'on
trouvait des
erreurs des des biais des des
erreurs d'interprétation par exemple
dans l'analyse des résultats et voilà et
c'est pas pourquoi je dis ça mais il me
semble que
si on entendait l'histoire d'une
découverte
on verrait que les personnages qui ont
participé n'étaient pas des esprits purs
et donc ces parents ne qu'il faut avoir
confiance par contre il faut avoir
confiance dans le processus qui a permis
d'obtenir une découverte
et si je peux donner un exemple il y a 3
ans je suis arrivé à centrale pour
donner un cours centrale Supélec pardon
pour donner un cours j'étais en avance
et j'avais des étudiants qui étaient là
en avance et ce cours se produisait le
lendemain du jour était paru un sondage
montrant que je sais pas comment était
fait sondage mais montrant que 17% des
Français
pensent que la terre est plate
ça me paraît beaucoup 17% mais
ceux qui pensent ça bon
en tout cas il y a beaucoup de sites sur
Internet d'ailleurs quand vous tapez sur
Google faites le c'est incroyable tapez
sur Google est-ce que la terre est plate
vous attendez est-ce que Google non elle
est ronde et voici pourquoi
maintenant Google vous oriente
les algorithmes de Google vous oriente
vers des sites
je ferme la parenthèse donc j'ai entendu
que mes étudiants étaient en train de se
moquer des gens qui pensent que la terre
est plate
vous avez raison de vous moquer c'est un
peu ridicule mais qui parmi vous serait
me dire comment on a su que la terre est
ronde
et là ça a été un silence
radio
ou 10 minutes qui m'a dit c'est Galilée
qui a démontré que la terre est ronde
ah bon Magellan a donc fait le tour du
monde en pensant partir sur une terre
plate
en fait on sait que la terre est ronde
depuis très longtemps tu as les Grecs le
savait les Indiens
3000 ans le savais on la détaxe
alors ils vont sortira Tostel mais non
arrête western il savait que la terre
était ronde c'est pour ça qu'il a mesuré
la circonférence en fait personne n'en
sait rien
voilà donc vous avez l'exemple d'une
connaissance une universellement
partagée
à 17% près
tout le monde sait que la terre est
ronde mais personne ne sait dire comment
on l'a su avant de le voir
alors je rappelle d'ailleurs que
l'association des Amis de la Terre plate
association américaine est née l'année
où pour la première fois un satellite à
photographier la terre
alors Jean-Marc
donc juste pour dire le square je l'ai
trouvé mon éditeur
il y a un truc qui va pas vous avez créé
une collection qui s'appelle que sais-je
c'est un titre bizarre parce que quand
je veux savoir ce que je sais je vais
pas acheter un livre
donc le titre que sais-je est bizarre
par contre vous allez créer une nouvelle
collection
qui s'appelle non pas que sais-je mais
qui s'appelle comment a-t-on su
comment a-t-on sué le premier cette
collection
c'est comment a-t-on su que la terre est
ronde c'est un truc passionnant parce
qu'on apprend plein de choses
c'est un truc passionnant mais je l'ai
lu voilà
alors
Jean-Marc à qui s'adressait en premier
pour convaincre que la terre n'est pas
ronde et que le climat change
que la terre n'est pas plateforme
alors j'en profite
j'en profite pour faire un petit moment
d'auto promo parce que j'ai créé une
collection chez Gallimard qui sur la
terre plate
qui s'appelle la connaissance est une
aventure et où justement il y avait un
titre comment sait-on que enfin comment
a-t-on compris que le singe allait au
cousin de l'homme comment a-t-on compris
que le climat très chauffe comment
l'homme a compris que je sais plus que
la terre est ronde ou un truc comme ça
quoi voilà
bien un jour j'ai discuté avec une
philosophie
qui m'a dit cette phrase qui m'a
c'est plongé dans un désespoir de
plusieurs nanosecondes elle m'a dit
alors je disais justement la terre est
ronde c'est une connaissance dont on va
pas très bien comment elle pourrait être
remise en cause dans le futur sauf si la
terre devient plate bon
elle m'a répondu cette phrase incroyable
on n'est pas à l'abri d'un nouvel
Einstein qui nous démontrera qu'elle est
plate
bon c'est le truc bizarre c'est Einstein
il faut un argument théorique pour
découvrir qu'elle est plate autrement
dit on n'est pas assez intelligent
comprendre qu'en fait elle est plate
et cet homme elle est professeurs
d'université et je me demande ce qu'elle
enseigne
Jean-Marc il va falloir qu'on conclure
alors qu'elle publique quel public en
premier notamment au shift tous
le public qu'on a choisi au Shift et pas
un public qu'on a choisi parce que c'est
nécessairement le plus important et on a
choisi parce que c'est des celui qui
était à notre portée il y a un
il y a un problème qu'il faut savoir
résoudre quand on s'adresse enfin pas
donc quand on s'attaque à un sujet aussi
protéiforme et universel que la question
de notre rapport aux limites planétaires
parce que finalement c'est ça le
c'est ça le sujet du changement
climatique c'est un sujet qui va pardon
embarquer la totalité de ce qu'on fait
partout et tout le temps puisque ça
concerne la manière dont on est organisé
ce qu'on consomme ce qu'on apprend ou à
tout le temps il faut savoir choisir ses
combats et faire la différence entre ce
qu'on est capable de faire est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire tout à l'heure on parlait
des émotions enfin en tout cas moi j'en
parlais il y a un truc qui est qui est
le j'ai envie de dire fréquent quand on
commence à comprendre cette histoire de
climat et encore une fois plus
généralement cette histoire de limite
planétaire c'est la sidération devant
l'ampleur de la tâche c'est-à-dire on se
dit il va falloir tout changer
absolument tout partout par quoi je
commence et à ce moment il y a un
facteur qui bloque souvent le passage à
l'action c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure des initiatives
locales collectives etc c'est de d'être
bien capable de comprendre que ou
d'accepter que ce qui est à sa portée
ne résoudra pas la totalité du problème
mais que de toute façon c'est un choix
entre ce qu'on peut faire et ce qu'on ne
peut pas faire et que la seule question
qui se pose à ce moment-là c'est
qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi c'est
pas est-ce que ça va résoudre la
totalité du problème c'est qu'est-ce que
je peux faire moi donc au chiffre c'est
ça c'est à cette question là qu'on a
répondu c'est qu'est-ce que je peux
faire moi alors au moment où le chiffre
a été créé il y avait un public que je
connaissais un peu qui était le monde
économique un comment dire une citadelle
a conquérir qui était la réconciliation
de la pensée économique avec les limites
physiques alors c'est une grosse
citadelle toujours pas conquise mais
c'était ça le public qui m'a et le la
voie d'entrée la plus la plus facile me
paraissait être de parler à une partie
des acteurs du monde économique qui
était justement dans l'effet mais cette
fois-ci utilisable à notre profit de
création d'une rente c'est-à-dire ceux
pour qui le fait de se dire cette
affaire de changement climatique est
sérieuse une est une bonne affaire pour
leur propre activité donc si on va
parler aux gens qui tirent des trains
qui vendent de la laine de verre ou qui
font fonctionner qui fabrique des vélos
ou qui font fonctionner des centrales
nucléaires ils vont avoir envie
d'écouter d'une oreille très attentive
le fait que cette histoire là c'est pas
du flan et que il faut s'agiter sur la
question donc c'est exactement ça qu'on
a fait quand on a créé le chiffre
project c'est s'appuyer sur des gens qui
tout bien pesaient en quelque chose à
gagner dans l'histoire si l'histoire
devient sérieuse parce que je suis
intimement convaincu à mon âge que la
société elle évolue sous l'effet de
confrontation d'intérêt et pas du tout
sous l'effet de
l'acquisition d'une compréhension
rationnelle du monde qui fait comprendre
des décisions rationnelles on prend pas
des décisions rationnelles on pilote
rationnellement nos désirs ce qui est
tout à fait différent donc il faut que
les désirs rejoignent le problème donc
faut s'adresser à des gens qui ont
commencé voilà donc commencez par le
fruit qui panse
comme voilà il faut que je passe la
parole au public donc c'est vraiment
indispensable
donc juste pour finir là-dessus donc
voilà donc on chiffre aussi attaque à ça
et ça reste quand même le monde
économique un levier important de
changement de la société puisque vous
l'aurez vu quand même dans les débats
qu'on fait au bout du bout il y a
énormément de débats de société qui à la
fin deviennent des débats économiques ah
il faudrait plus d'enseignants mais
combien ça coûte ah il faudrait changer
la façon dont on organise tel ou tel
machin mais combien ça coûte ah il
faudrait modifier les pratiques
agricoles mais combien ça coûte donc le
monde et le raisonnement économique sont
quand même extrêmement prévenant dans
notre structuration de la prise de
décision aujourd'hui donc certes quand
on a créé le chiffre project on n'avait
pas la prétention de s'attaquer à tout
partout et tout le temps mais pour
autant on n'avait pas non plus
l'impression de traiter une partie
epsilonesque des acteurs qui ont une
influence importante sur la façon dont
l'avenir va s'écrire
merci à tous les deux on va maintenant
prendre les questions du public qui j'en
suis sûre son nombreuse et je ne sais
pas bah alors sans micro
bonjour et merci pour cet échange
passionnant
plein de réactions à tout ce que vous
avez dit il va falloir que je choisisse
à la fresque il y a deux promesses il y
a la première promesse c'est les gens
qui participent ils vont pendant trois
heures avoir l'opportunité souvent de
regarder un truc qu'ils avaient pas
envie de regarder et la deuxième
promesse c'est
pour les animateurs ou ceux qui voudront
le devenir de passer dans le camp de ce
qui font quelque chose c'est ça les
animateurs aujourd'hui il y a des
milliers d'animateurs qui essayent de
faire ça
et on fait ça très mal
pas aussi bien que vous
on fait ça comme on peut alors ma
question à vous ça fait quelques années
l'un et l'autre que vous faites de la
vulgarisation
c'est quoi votre conseil à des gens qui
sont fresqueurs qui ont à peu près
compris les enjeux qui ont envie de
faire des choses de faire passer des
messages et qui ont peut-être pas votre
talent pour le faire
je commence alors je vais je suis pas
sûr que je vais répondre à la hauteur
des attentes à cette question parce que
je ne suis pas animateur de la fresque
du climat et faire une intervention
c'est un exercice différent
d'animer des groupes donc j'en ai fait
une de fraises mais c'est très différent
de d'animer un groupe de joueurs par
parce que c'est pas les mêmes techniques
c'est pas les mêmes ressorts par rapport
à faire une intervention qui comporte
une partie très descendante au début
avant que les gens dans les bons cas de
figure crachent leur tripes et dans les
mauvais s'en aille sans dire un mot
donc dans ce que j'ai vu de la fresque
pour l'avoir faite c'est que on est dans
une dynamique qui est tout à fait
différente et il me semble que la
technicité et le talent de l'animateur
il est beaucoup plus dans le fait de
motiver les gens à jouer que dans le
parce qu'ils vont découvrir par
eux-mêmes en jouant que dans le fait de
les
d'éveiller j'ai envie de dire leur
curiosité à travers un simple discours
ou à travers des supports PowerPoint ou
je sais pas quoi donc c'est c'est pas de
le même genre c'est pas le même genre
d'exercice à mon avis un des points
communs c'est que moi j'aime bien les
interventions dans des publics qu'on
prend un peu par surprise
qui sont à la fois des publics plus
difficiles mais ceux auxquels on va
vraiment apprendre quelque chose parce
que ceux qui viennent volontairement à
une conférence que je fais maintenant en
fait j'évite je fais plus de conférences
grand public parce que je sais très bien
que je vais avoir que des gens qui ont
déjà écouté 50 fois ce que j'ai raconté
donc la valeur ajoutée que je peux avoir
est nulle donc quand maintenant on
propose des trucs grand public je dis
toujours non parce qu'en fait ça sera
jamais grand public ça va être restreint
aux gens qui savent justement avec en
plus ce piège qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure de de d'augmenter ma propre
confiance dans le fait que les gens sont
motivés parce que je vois il y a un bien
il y a un biais de sélection dans
l'échantillon que j'ai en face de moi
qui augmente à mesure que le temps passe
donc les gens qui m'intéressent c'est
les gens pris par surprise donc c'est
des séminaires d'entreprises à qui on a
rien demandé et je pense que la fresque
du climat correspond plus dans les bons
cas de figure à ce genre de public
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont rien
demandé il y a quelqu'un qui a dit tiens
ça serait rigolo de faire ça il a réussi
à convaincre je sais pas qui de louer
une salle et de coincer les gens c'est
encore plus vrai pour les élèves à qui
on demande pas leur avis avant de les
envoyer en classe donc c'est c'est et là
quand on prend les gens par surprise le
le la technique qui marche le mieux mais
c'est déjà celle de la fresque puisque
les gens doivent chercher c'est la
technique de la question-réponse est-ce
que vous savez pourquoi donc voilà
est-ce que vous avez une idée de est-ce
que etc puis avec des trucs un peu
marrants voilà c'est donc c'est la
technique du quiz qui leur permet de
rentrer dans le dans la dynamique et dès
que vous avez commencé à leur donner
envie de chercher le jeu est lancé
puisque la fresque encore une fois ça
n'est que ça c'est une espèce de jeu de
piste quoi au fond c'est le jeu de piste
du climat quoi donc il suffit de donner
envie aux gens de commencer à chercher
après le reste j'ai envie de dire se
passe tout seul et la dernière chose je
pense que j'en ai vu qui me paraît
importante donc c'est peut-être là que
les animateurs de temps en temps se
sentent un peu inconfortable c'est que
il faut être capable de répondre aux
questions en cours de route sur pourquoi
c'est comme ça donc là vous me dites que
pourquoi c'est comme ça et alors là par
contre je pense que il y a un vrai sujet
parce que le défaut de réponse peut
mettre les gens dans une rupture de
confiance vis-à-vis de la dynamique
voilà donc je pense que c'est surtout ça
qui est le le point qui peut
éventuellement être à travailler là il y
a pas tellement d'autres manières
d'apprendre que l'expérience
c'est-à-dire on se fait avoir une fois
bah on se dit qu'on se fera pas avoir
une deuxième quoi non mais
mais on a aussi le droit de dire on sait
pas en tant qu'animateur oui absolument
il y a une question au fond
pour avoir animé quelques fresques du
climat je suis aussi shifter c'est
vraiment la synergie entre les
participants c'est à dire que on croit
que les participants connaissent peu
mais finalement c'est pas vrai et il se
passer réellement un transfert de
connaissances de compétences
moi je trouve que c'est ce qui est le
plus constructif synergies entre les
participants voilà d'accord en fait
monsieur vous répondez à la question de
Frédéric
est-ce que vous avez une question
vous-même
merci beaucoup est-ce que ceux qui
veulent poser une question peuvent lever
la main s'il vous plaît donc j'envoie
une là
une
bonjour
il me semble que tout opinion toute
conviction toute nouvelle connaissance
doit s'imbriquer dans les opinions
conviction qu'on a déjà il y a une sorte
d'écosystème mental est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est
cette vulgarisation sur le changement
climatique a du mal à faire sa place
dans les opinions qui sont déjà
fréquemment dans la tête des gens et
est-ce comment comment devrait-on réagir
selon vous
alors petit exemple que j'ai en tête le
progrès humain est inexerable il est
peut-être une guerre mondiale quelque
chose comme ça mais à quelques coups de
frein près le progrès est inexorable
donc la déstabilisation du climat c'est
pas possible c'est ou alors c'est un
problème mineur qu'on va contourner
est-ce que ces deux convictions se
sont en contradiction par exemple en
tant que philosophe
[Musique]
de ce que je ressens comme vulgarisateur
c'est à dire que si vous m'aviez posé la
question il y a deux ans je vous aurais
dit pour faire de la bonne vulgarisation
faut choisir un sujet et le travailler à
fond moi c'était la physique quantique
donc j'ai étudié les équations la
physique quantique le formalisent les
implications philosophiques l'histoire
de la physique quantique la vie et
l'oeuvre des pères fondateurs de la
physique quantique le type de problème
qu'ils avaient à résoudre ça m'a pris
des années et une fois qu'on a fait ce
travail on se sent capable à taureau a
raison de parler à différents publics
prisonniers
parlementaire étudiant collégien grand
public etc et on tombe évidemment dans
le biais que vient de rappeler Jean-Marc
à savoir qu'on a l'impression que ça
marche
on a l'impression que ça marche les gens
viennent aux conférences posent des
questions intelligentes on corrige les
copies des étudiants ils ont compris le
truc on écrit des livres on reçoit du
courrier des lecteurs visiblement les
gens ont compris le bouquin donc on dit
purée ça marche en fait ça ne marche
qu'auprès des gens qui s'intéressent à
la vulgarisation c'est-à-dire une
fraction minimale de la population
et ça c'est le covid qui me l'a montré
voilà moi j'ai en voyant le covid que
j'ai compris que la vulgarisation c'est
un échec voilà
un échec relatif pour mettre un peu
d'Einstein dans l'affaire mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'on nous repention nos
moyens d'accès au grand public voilà et
et le grand public lui il entend des
choses il est soumis à un flux
d'informations
en fait dans les mêmes canaux de
communication circulent des
connaissances scientifiques ou pas des
croyances des opinions des commentaires
des bobards
et toutes ces choses circulant ensemble
bien qu'ayant des statues différents CE
contaminent quand vous avez à faire une
connaissance on va vous dire mais est-ce
que c'est pas la croyance d'une
communauté particulière en l'occurrence
avec climatologue qui sonne sur de
communauté qui aurait intérêt à graver
la situation pour avoir des rentes et
puis quand vous avez affaire une
croyance on va vous dire est-ce que
cette croyance n'est pas une
connaissance qui aurait été injustement
méprisée dans de sagesse populaire sur
la question du progrès quand même
[Musique]
on a fait ça avec un collègue de
l'Académie des technologique qui
s'appelle Gérald Brenner on a étudié un
logiciel qui compte l'occurrence des
mots dans les discours publics
et on a vu ce que tout le monde devine
ce mot progrès qui a été écrit pendant
trois siècles avec une lettre majuscule
à perdre du sa majuscule après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et il a commencé sa lente des
croissances en 1981
époque où apparaît un mot très ancien
qui réactivé
à l'époque quel mot innovation
le mot innovation monte monte le
croisement de la courbe du progrès qui
descend et la courbe de l'innovation qui
monte se produit en 2003
et la disparition complète du mot du mot
progrès pardon dans les discours publics
se produit dans le quinquennat 2007-2012
vous pouvez le vérifier simplement tous
les candidats de la présidentielle en
2016 utilisent le mot progrès dans leur
rhétorique en 2012 plus aucun et à
quelle année il y a donc on pourrait
dire on pourrait dire finalement
le mot progrès c'est modernisé on l'a
fait progresser on le remplaçant par le
mot innovation qui est plus moderne en
fait c'est fou le mot innovation ça
serait une histoire mais plus ancien que
nos progrès mais peu importe et on
pourrait dire on a fait une permutation
de mots mais c'est le même message et en
fait quand on regarde ça demande du
temps que j'ai pas
comment la rhétorique de l'innovation se
déploie on constate qu'elle contredit la
rhétorique du progrès pour le dire en
une phrase la rhétique du progrès
suppose que le temps qui passe est
constructeur donc il est complice de
notre liberté et de notre volonté il est
notre allié
la rhétorique de l'innovation est
complètement différente on dit qu'on est
soumis à toutes sortes de défis
climatiques vieillissement de la
population etc et nous avons compris
dit-on que nous ne pourrons relever ces
défis dans la gravité augmente à mesure
que le temps passe
que par l'innovation
et donc l'innovation c'est un principe
de conservation
qui est destiné à pallier les effets
corrupteurs du temps qui passe
et donc voyez la rétorégulation s'appuie
sur l'idée d'un temps corrupteur et non
pas constructeur c'est passionnant on
pourrait en parler pendant une heure
encore plus il faut plus vraiment je
regrette de devoir vous couper la parole
pour pour
très pratique
sur la question de alors quand on vous
pose ce genre de questions mais le
progrès met aussi en fait c'est pas une
question c'est une objection ce qu'il
faut essayer de comprendre c'est quelle
est la motivation de la personne qui
vous pose la question très souvent en
fait il répond à sa propre
déstabilisation c'est à dire que en fait
comme vous lui posez un problème auquel
il voit pas de solution évidente il a
envie de nier le problème parce que
c'est ça qui le ramène dans une zone de
confort où l'avenir et de nouveau
quelque chose qui n'est pas menaçant
donc quand on répond à ce genre
d'objection il y a deux choses qu'il
faut garder en tête c'est un il faut
dire explicitement à mon avis que vous
comprenez son désarroi alors il y a
plusieurs manières de le dire il faut le
dire aussi explicitement que ça moi des
fois je le fais vous pouvez le dire
parfois moins explicitement mais en gros
il faut d'entrer de jeu mettre son
objection dans la position de quelqu'un
qui exprime légitimement une angoisse
d'accord dès que vous faites ça quelque
part vous apaisez le débat parce que
vous lui dites pas c'est un abruti qui
n'a rien compris vous lui dites vous
exprimez une réaction tout à fait
normale qui est celle de quelqu'un qui
qui se retrouve totalement déstabilisés
la deuxième chose qu'il faut avoir
présent à l'esprit quand on répond à ce
genre de choses c'est que vous répondez
autant à la personne qu'à tous les
autres qui écoutent c'est à dire que
même si vous arrivez pas à convaincre la
personne qui qui que vous avez en face
de vous c'est important de lui répondre
parce que tous les autres qui sont
présents dans le dans l'assistance vont
peser les arguments des uns et des
autres pour se faire leur propre opinion
donc la alors moi c'est une règle que
j'ai très fréquemment présente à
l'esprit avec les climatosceptiques
entre guillemets quand il y en a un qui
m'envoie un mail privé parce que ça
m'arrive de temps en temps je reçois un
mail de quelqu'un qui me dit vous avez
rien compris je n'y réponds jamais enfin
que je répondrai poliment en une phrase
en lui disant j'espère pas vous
convaincre je pense que ça ne s'est pas
possible au revoir Monsieur Merci par
contre quand c'est dans les 100
l'enceinte publique il faut toujours y
répondre parce que vous vous ne le
convaincez pas enfin la personne qui
vous fait l'objection jamais vous la
convaincrez par contre la nature du
débat est essentiel pour les autres qui
sont pour l'essentiel de bonne foi et
qui ont quand même envie de savoir ce
que vous avez envie ce que vous avez ce
que vous répondez sur l'argument de fond
donc vous répondez pas l'individu vous
répondez à l'argument voilà donc c'est
c'est quelque trucs et astuces qu'il
faut avoir présent à l'esprit mais
encore une fois et bien conscience du
fait que ce genre de réaction c'est
totalement normal parce que c'est
l'expression d'un désarroi qui est
totalement normal à la limite il y a pas
de désarroi après qu'on ait parlé du
changement climatique c'est que c'est
une un échec ça veut dire que les gens
n'ont rien compris merci Jean-Marc une
question ici bonjour Merci beaucoup donc
merci pour cet échange passionnant donc
j'ai même pas mal de dire puisque j'ai
écouté
moi j'aimerais bien revenir la toute
première question en fait qui a été
posée sur comment passer en fait de la
connaissance à l'action finalement pour
le climat il me semble qu'il y a trois
composantes en fait à cette cette
question donc la première qui est
pourquoi il faut changer donc là il y a
un constat scientifique on parle
justement de la vulgarisation de la
connaissance autour de ça après il y a
une question ce qui est donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire donc quelle réponse
finalement quelle solution vient te
porter là encore une fois on a des
experts qui peuvent voilà nous orienter
nous en fait partie évidemment sur cette
villeurisation et moi il me semble qu'il
y a une troisième composante qui
manquante ou j'aimerais bien avoir vous
du coup votre avis là-dessus c'est un
peu la vulgarisation sur comment le
faire comment justement on se met en
mouvement comment on peut mobiliser donc
la société donc les différentes
audiences autour de l'action climat et
est-ce que là il n'y a pas peut-être
aussi des compétences à chercher qui
seraient complémentaires notamment je
pense aux sciences sociales et donc là
la question c'est est-ce que vous avez
connaissance des initiatives donc un peu
transisciplinaire entre les séances
dures les sciences sociales si ou non et
comment le faire donc ne peut pas vous
connaissances de favoriser
professionnelle comment on peut
atteindre cette transition
merci
le
je vais faire une réponse philosophique
comme ça ça donnera l'occasion à mon
voisin de de non non pas du tout au
contraire de contredire ou d'embrayer
qui est faut-il changer j'en sais rien
moi c'est pas une vérité scientifique de
changer ça c'est un choix collectif dans
la question du changement climatique il
est du rôle de la science d'éclairer le
débat maintenant savoir si on doit se
goberger tant que ça passe et advienne
que pourra derrière ou si on doit se
mettre au régime tout de suite c'est pas
une vérité scientifique ça c'est un
choix
c'est un choix moral c'est un choix
éthique c'est pas du tout un choix
scientifique donc quand personnellement
je milite pour que on y aille mollo sur
la question des émissions gaz à effet de
serre j'exprime une préférence c'est pas
du tout une vérité scientifique que
j'exprime j'exprime une préférence et je
pense que là aussi c'est essentiel et ça
renvoie la question du désarroi il faut
il y a des gens qui vont dire tant que
ça passe on s'en fait péter la panse et
ensuite on verra bien c'est une forme de
préférence discutons-en bon alors après
si on est du côté des gens qui préfèrent
que on a pu un peu sur la [ __ ] de
frein
le la question sur comment on passe à
l'action
je me méfie énormément des règles
génériques et générales sur il y a qu'à
mettre ensemble des physiciens et des
sociologues et tout se passera bien non
pas qu'il faille pas le faire mais je
vais un tout petit peu préciser là en
fait on rentre dans un milliard de
problèmes pratiques donc je vais en
revenir à nos amis Tyrol et Blanchard
il vous répondent prix du carbone tout
simplement parce que les économistes de
de la ils n'ont qu'un seul outil à leur
disposition c'est des modèles dans
lesquels il y a un prix du carbone donc
ils vont vous parler de prix du carbone
où est-ce que le prix du carbone
intervient si vous devez reconvertir des
gens qui fabriquent des pneus pour qu'il
fabrique des routes bicyclette pour
expliquer je vois pas où par contre ça
c'est un problème très pratique si vous
voulez remettre 500 000 personnes dans
l'agriculture où est le prix du carbone
comme les chers tête blonde là qui
sortent du système éducatif et à qui on
leur dit si tu es bon tu iras à la fac
écouter Étienne Klein et si tu es
mauvais tu viendras plombier où est le
prix du carbone dans cette histoire et
aucun problème de prix du carbone donc
le fait de régler les problèmes en fait
on tombe sur quelque chose qui est un
milliard de problèmes pratiques à régler
on est plus du tout dans les grandes
théories générales on est dans à chaque
fois comment est-ce que au sein du
problème qu'on regarde on est capable de
décliner la préférence collective
générale qu'on a exprimé avant qui est
jarbitre en faveur de l'avenir c'est un
arbitrage temporel cette histoire c'est
je préserve mieux l'avenir et du coup je
vais un peu plus me priver tout de suite
c'est c'est le je change le bénéfice de
nature
l'idée qu'on va gagner partout et tout
le temps sur tous les tableaux c'est pas
vrai donc quand il y a des gens même que
j'aime bien qui disent tout le monde à
tout à y gagner à s'occuper du
changement climatique c'est pas vrai
tous autant que nous sommes on a tous
quelque chose et y perdre à court terme
bon donc le le passage à l'action il est
dans le fait de d'arbitrer de faire une
hiérarchie des annoncement et une
hiérarchie des préférences d'être
capable de la gérer et d'être capable de
décliner ça dans un milliard de
problèmes pratiques y compris la manière
dont on gère les salons de coiffure donc
le le passage à l'action il va demander
des compétences qui varient en fonction
du domaine qu'on est en train de
regarder
que là-dedans il est pas que de la
science dur est une absolue évidence je
parlais tout à l'heure de la gestion des
émotions c'est pas de la science dur ça
c'est même pas de la science tout court
enfin on peut avoir une démarche
scientifique dans la façon dont les gens
réagissent c'est à dire faire
de des observations statistiques savoir
que mis dans telle situation il y a 45%
des gens qui préfèrent agir comme ça et
55 qui préfèrent réagir autrement ça oui
ça aide donc les sciences sociales qui
ont une capacité à orienter l'action
sont extrêmement utiles celles qui sont
purement qualitatives c'est plus
compliqué d'en faire quelque chose donc
même au sein d'une discipline il y a des
il va y avoir des choses qui vont être
utiles quand il s'agit de passer à
l'action et d'autres qui restent très
théoriques et qui vont être beaucoup
plus difficiles à exploiter voilà mais
j'insiste vraiment sur un point c'est
que quand on passe à l'action c'est un
milliard de problèmes pratiques c'est
c'est beaucoup moins des grandes
théories générales alors les problèmes
pratiques s'organisent se planifient du
reste au shift on va proposer on est en
train de travailler à proposer notre
propre planification sur la façon de
décarboner l'économie c'est le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
là certains d'entre vous sont peut-être
au courant qui où il y a plein de
rapports intermédiaires qui sortent en
ce moment là et qui sont ouverts à la
critique à la réfutation alors donc si
vous avez un peu le temps pour les lire
et faire des remarques allez-y
et le donc on va on va faire une
proposition à la rentrée de plan
opérationnel et à ce plan opérationnel
on travaillait des gens de plein de
disciplines différentes mais ça peut
être des gens qui gèrent des livraisons
dans une boîte de fret comme ça peut
être des gens qui font de la sociologie
universitaire donc il y aura tout
là-dedans voilà mais j'insiste vraiment
sur le sur le encore une fois c'est des
problèmes pratiques
qu'on a à résoudre à un moment et ces
problèmes pratiques renvoient toujours à
une hiérarchie des préférences qui ne
relèvent pas de la science dur qui
relève vraiment de la voilà donc ce
qu'on peut faire c'est éclairer ce choix
mais on
un moment c'est un choix merci Jean-Marc
une question au fond oui bonjour
alors ces échanges je me posais la
question aujourd'hui journée aussi
presque du climat orienté entreprise la
notion de temporalité de temps court
temps long temps court au niveau des
acteurs économiques justement qui ont
des pressions de reporting économiques
courtes par opposition au temps long
étant physique du climat et la troisième
notion d'urgence climatique en fait
comment nous aujourd'hui au quotidien en
tant qu'acteur dans nos entreprises
réussir à faire ce grand écart entre
temps court temps long réussir à
convaincre en face de nous nos
interlocuteurs économiques financiers
avec ces notions justement et c'est
déploiements de fresques du climat en
entreprise merci beaucoup à vous donc
temps court temps long urgence
je sens que vous attendez une réponse
mais c'est une question trop difficile
pour moi déjà dans l'expression urgence
climatique je me demande s'il y a pas
une contradiction de quoi de quoi on
parle puisqu'on vient de dire que la
temporalité
du changement climatique est une
temporalité très longue que l'agir
immédiat n'a pas d'effet à court terme
c'est pour le long terme que les effets
se feront voir donc quand on parle de
l'urgence climatique on sans doute
parler de l'urgence à agir et c'est
urgence à agir n'aura pas d'effets
rapides et ça je pense que c'est la
grande difficulté de cette pédagogie
mais pour revenir à ce que disait
Jean-Marc
on a compris quand même une chose c'est
que la science qui produit des
connaissances produit aussi et surtout
de l'incertitude mais c'est une
incertitude d'un type très spécial c'est
que la science ne vous dit pas
ce que vous devez faire des
connaissances qu'elle vous donne
la physique nucléaire ne vous dit pas si
vous devez faire des centrales
nucléaires
elle vous dit comment les faire
la biologie ne vous dit pas si vous
devez faire des OGM elle vous dit que
vous pouvez les faire
la climatologie vous dit ce qui s'est
passé ce qui se passe et ce qui va se
passer
elle ne vous dit pas ce que vous devez
faire compte tenu de ces connaissances
et donc je pense que on est dans une
société qui a besoin de débattre du type
de compagnonnage
que collectivement nous allons
organiser
à partir de ces connaissances
sur les OGM sur le nucléaire sur la 5G
c'est toujours la même question d'accord
et le problème c'est qu'on sait pas
faire alors vous parlez des sociologues
il faudrait peut-être inventer une
ingénie sociale pour apprendre à
débattre je vous rappelle que c'est ma
conclusion le verbe débattre c'est un
très vieux mot de la langue française
c'est un mot du 12e siècle
qui veut dire quoi
étymologiquement il veut dire ce qu'il
faut faire
ce qu'il faut faire pour ne pas avoir à
se battre
donc débattre c'est le contraire de
combattre
ça veut dire argumenter discuter
ensemble pratiquer une politesse de
l'esprit refuser les arguments
d'autorité ça prend un temps fou ça
prend un temps fou et c'est parfois
emmerdant et on préfère nous le débat au
sens moderne du terme c'est les clashs
des clashs sont aux personnes dont on
connaît les positions opposées et dont
on organise les confrontations et je
pense que le débat au sens premier du
terme il faudrait trouver le moyen de le
réorganiser parce que aujourd'hui on
voit bien que le fait d'avoir une
opinion c'est paradoxal mais le fait
d'avoir une opinion dédouane de l'envie
et de l'obligation de s'instruire de
ceux à propos de quoi on opinion un
chiffre frappé autour de moi mes amis
qui sont contre la 5G
savent pas ce que c'est un objet mes
amis qui sont pour le nucléaire ils
savent pas pourquoi amélioranium dans
les centrales je dis pourquoi moi
pourquoi on met pas du rubidium
on devrait faire des centrales au
rugbyllium ça nous changerait voilà et
donc vous voyez c'est ça le problème
c'est que avoir une opinion c'est
exactement le contraire de se forger une
opinion se forger une opinion de travail
etc merci Etienne la dernière des
dernières questions pierre bonjour merci
beaucoup pour vos interventions on
s'accorde sur le fait que ça va être le
diagnostic qui va déclencher le
changement et donc qu'avant l'urgence
d'agir il y a l'urgence d'informer que
la fresque du climat est un très bon
outil pour le faire tout ça pour arriver
à un petit ordre de grandeur pardon je
m'adresse à vous monsieur Jancovici
aujourd'hui on est 6000 animateurs de la
fresque du climat vous avez une base de
300000 followers je crois sur Linkedin
est-ce que vous serez prêt à faire un
appel à la mobilisation générale de
messager qui puisse relayer ses
connaissances
un appel général à quoi à la
mobilisation de tous les gens qui
s'intéressent au sujet qui sont déjà un
peu informés pour qu'ils puissent
Sailler et relier ses connaissances dans
toute leur sphère de vie qu'elle soit
familiale professionnelle ou amicale
c'est à dire qu'ils deviennent tous
animateurs de la fresque grosso modo
faut pas avoir peur
je relaye assez souvent les initiatives
de la fresque du climat donc pour autant
que je sois au courant en général je
parce que j'ai encore une fois je trouve
que c'est un
une très belle initiative quelque chose
qui correspond à un vrai besoin
sacoche beaucoup de cases c'est tout à
l'heure on parlait de la question de la
dynamique le fait de faire un jeu par
équipe ça rend les gens collaboratifs au
sein de chaque équipe c'est un truc que
comme le monde ça marche bien donc les
gens s'entraident donc tout à l'heure il
y a une personne qui avait fait
remarquer que les gens se passaient à
des connaissances dans le cadre du jeu
mais c'est normal c'est la dynamique qui
veut ça puisque c'est un jeu par équipe
donc au sein d'une équipe les gens se
les gens s'entraident sur la question de
au sein d'une entreprise comment faire
pour convaincre mes patrons et le reste
en haut il y a pas de recette miracle ça
je peux vous dire donc il faut du temps
une entreprise c'est à la fois une
petite dictature une petite démocratie
il y a un truc qui est compliqué dans
une entreprise c'est que quand
l'essentiel des collaborateurs
commencent à dire là il faut s'occuper
d'un problème c'est de l'ignorer donc
de faire faut diffuser jusqu'au moment
où il y a de monde en interne pour dire
ce truc est important donc il faut s'en
occuper et à ce moment nécessairement
il finira par se passer quelque chose au
sein des instances dirigeantes de la
boîte c'est ça aussi c'est une c'est
quelque chose qui marche qui marche très
bien
donc font finir de de relayer les enfin
pour finir sur la question du relais je
vais finir par un truc que j'ai déjà dit
par ailleurs quand je dis c'est
vachement bien la fresque du climat aux
gens qui me suivent sur Linkedin je
m'adresse pour l'essentiel à des gens
qui sont déjà convaincus rappelez-vous
que LinkedIn et les réseaux sociaux
d'une manière générale c'est du
communautarisme pur jus donc les gens
qui viennent s'inscrire sur mon feel
LinkedIn c'est ça fait partie au sein de
la population française des gens du
sous-échantillon à qui j'ai le moins à
apprendre quelque part qui ont alors ils
sont quand même important ces gens là
parce que ils vont eux-mêmes être des
relais des ambassadeurs etc plus ou
moins facilement c'est dans la limite de
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est
beaucoup plus facile de militer dans un
cercle dans lequel il y a déjà quelque
chose de collectif quand les gens sont
déjà rassemblés par quelque chose c'est
c'est plus facile donc là où je vais
finir par ça je pense qu'il y a il y a
un gros travail à mener qui concerne
toutes les organisations militantes et
j'ins sur le fait que ces militants donc
c'est pour répondre à la question tout à
l'heure c'est pas une vérité
scientifique de vouloir s'occuper du
changement climatique c'est un
militantisme c'est quelque part accepter
de ranger les problèmes dans un certain
ordre plutôt que dans un autre c'est
c'est ça et bien le il y a une question
à se poser qui est de savoir comment
est-ce que on rend les gens intéressés
par le sujet qu'on manipule parce que
une autre manière aussi d'éviter l'effet
de grossisation dont on parle tout à
l'heure quand on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est d'avoir des gens qui concernent de
la hauteur de vue et qui donc
viennent en exerçant un esprit critique
parce qu'ils ont un intérêt qui qui est
fait comme ça bon et il faut favoriser
ça il faut favoriser ça voilà donc pour
finir sur la question très pratique il
m'arrive de relayer des des
initiatives de la fresque parce que
encore une fois je trouve que c'est une
action qui est extrêmement utile et
pertinente
et à mon avis efficace merci Jean-Marc
donc Cédric un mot merci oui juste une
annonce donc je profite merci déjà
Etienne et Jean-Marc pour d'être
intervenu aujourd'hui je voulais passer
une petite annonce et profiter surtout à
destination des gens qui nous regardent
sur les réseaux sociaux la fresque vient
de lancer un financement participatif un
crowdfunding dans le but de nous donner
encore plus de moyens pour passer à
l'échelle au niveau international donc
vous trouverez les informations sur le
site Internet et probablement également
sur les réseaux sociaux en dessous de de
là où vous êtes pour l'instant en train
de regarder sur youtube ou sur Facebook
le but pour nous c'est de financer notre
notre capacité à aller à Glasgow à
mobiliser du monde à être présent sur
place notre objectif c'est que il n'y
ait pas un seul négociateur du climat
qui n'est pas vu au moins une fresque
sur un mur ou qui est qui est pas eu
l'occasion de jouer à la fresque de voir
des gens jouer donc voilà un peu nos
enjeux pour pour la suite on a fait
quelque chose extraordinaire en France
grâce à toute la communauté à tous les
frères et les fresque que je remercie et
maintenant le but c'est de passer à
l'international alors on est déjà
présent dans une quarantaine de pays
mais il s'agit maintenant d'y rentrer
par les institutionnels et c'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir faire à la coque avec
avec votre aide à tous que ce soit en
relayant en finançant ou en rejoignant
la communauté et du coup Juliette je te
laisse conclure alors moi ma conclusion
c'est un grand merci à Étienne Klein et
à Jean-Marc Jancovici que je vais vous
demander d'applaudir parce que vraiment
je pense que
[Applaudissements]
voilà
donc c'était c'était vraiment un plaisir
d'avoir animé ce débat j'espère que pour
tout le monde aussi enfin voilà c'était
passionnant ça aurait pu encore durer
des heures mais le temps file et on
passe à la suite donc merci encore et à
bientôt j'espère
[Applaudissements]
dans un quart d'heure la conférence de
presse donc ceux qui sont censés
assister vous pouvez garder vos places
ou aller faire un tour mais